This is Jocko podcast number one 33 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
Okay.
And this podcast will cover a horrific subject.
History.
And it is not for children or the faint of heart.
So listener discretion is advised.
Okay.
I am a war criminal.
I served in men Chuko that phony country created by Japan.
Okay.
In 1992 a group of us
went to China to apologize to the family members of the people we had sent to
unit seven 31
one woman.
Now about 60 was the grandchild of one of the victims.
She told us our grandfather was killed by units seven 31 in experiments.
Okay.
He was killed because the Ken p ty sent him.
If you hadn't sent him,
he would've lived.
You are killers.
Just like those doctors.
We prostrate ourselves and apology and she kept pressing the fact home that we
were partners in crime as guilty as the doctors of unit seven 31
and it's true.
Okay?
It is just as she said,
apologizing does not erase the crime.
We were the aggressors.
Most of the Japanese participants in the war were aggressors.
Orders came from above orders from the emperor.
Okay.
Then people were killed because it couldn't be helped.
According to international convention,
those who killed in combat or not criminals,
the 3000 people killed by units,
seven 31 were all sent there by the Ken Pti or the police.
The American navy was attacked at Pearl Harbor and the Japanese thought it was a
Victoria strike.
Yeah.
Within two years,
America had built up its naval strength.
Again,
America is a machine society,
but bacteriological warfare does not rely on machines.
So each,
she's idea was to kill the attacking Russians with disease.
Once killed troops are not rebuilt like machinery.
The Japanese to army promised Chinese children money for bringing in rats.
The later gave them a pencil for every rat.
The end purpose of all this effort
was war
in war.
The side who kills more people wins.
Okay.
Bacteria can kill on a large scale.
So he,
she pressed this forward
and that
his testimony from a Kenty pie officer,
which was kind of like a secret police that served in Japan leading up to and
during World War Two
and
this is a part of history that,
okay,
I don't really want to talk about,
no one does,
but of course to ignore it.
Okay.
To think that if we pretend it didn't happen,
that only opens up the door for it to happen again.
So this is the story of unit seven 31 and arm of the Japanese imperial army that
along with some other associated units,
they developed,
tested and deployed chemical and biological warfare weapons.
Okay.
Then there's two books that I reviewed and we'll be referring to during this
podcast.
One is a unit seven 31 by Pete Williams and David Wallace and the other is unit
seven 31 testimony
by how gold
and
the history and the acts that are accounted for in these books really show what
man is capable of.
Okay.
Especially on a malevolent leadership.
And in this case,
the leader that is primarily culpable for the crimes of unit seven 31 is the
individual referred to in that opening statement.
A guy named by the name of each,
she shiro,
he,
she who was born June 25th,
1892 the fourth son in a wealthy land owning family.
He was a smart,
apparently very smart individual.
He was a big,
tall kind of strapping guy.
Then by most accounts he was a pretty arrogant individual as well.
And he went to school to become a doctor and join the army.
And there he studied
okay,
bacteriology and serology,
which is the study of blood and pathogens in the blood.
And he was also a fiercely patriotic and nationalistic individual.
And what that meant in Japan at this time was a feeling of total superiority,
both a cultural superiority and a racial superiority,
cultural and racial superiority,
superiority over the rest of Asia and really over the rest of the world.
And he moved up through the ranks fairly quickly and he had done some traveling
and of course saw what things that happened in world war one.
And he saw chemical and biological warfare as a way to win wars.
And obviously Japan is a island nation with limited resources and so you need
some advantage.
And he thought the advantage that Japan could get was chemical and biological
warfare.
And in order to really maximize that advantage,
he believed that these weapons needed to be tested on people.
Yeah.
He believed that human experimentation was the pathway to move ahead of the rest
of the world technologically in these departments.
And oddly enough,
he gained a decent amount of clout and prestige by inventing a water filtration
system that could provide clean water to soldiers on the front line,
which was a really big deal.
And,
and the book,
the book testimony,
the unit seven 31 when he goes into pretty good detail about the number of
people that were killed in wars back then and how many of them would die of
diseases and in malnutrition from being sick from the water having diseases and
whatnot.
And so he developed this,
this filtration system that worked really well and he ended up actually taking
advantage of that a little too much.
And he used that technology,
which he'd come up with to get some kickback payments from a commercial company
that manufactured the filters and that kind of got them in some trouble.
But that troubles overcome because he had some political connections that he had
gained and he'd gotten it,
got back on path and continue to gain rank and,
and gain.
And with that rank and that stature that he gained,
he convinced his leadership to allow him to begin a highly secret program where
he would make and test the biological and chemical weapons.
And again,
at this time,
chemical and biological weapons were very politically sensitive.
So this is in the mid 1930 is the end of world war one had had only occurred
just prior to this really 20 years.
And
people remembered those,
those wars,
that war and they remembered the horrors of those weapons.
And,
and that's why international law had forbidden these weapons,
buddy.
She didn't care.
She was there to win at any cost.
And because of the view of the chemical and biological weapons at this time and
the political sensitivity around them,
he couldn't do what he wanted to do inside of Japan
because these weapons are dangerous,
first of all.
But again,
the political sensitivities around them,
that was okay because he had other plans and he opened his first laboratory in
Manchuria,
an area of China that was at this time under the brutal control of imperial
Japan.
And the first laboratory that he put together was outside of a city called
Harbin.
And interestingly,
the unit maintained a level of cover,
meaning their,
their purpose wasn't made known to the world.
The people they advertise,
the unit that they put in Manchuria,
that it was all about water purification and they,
and they actually did water purification there.
So it was a good cover story.
Okay.
But what was really being focused on underneath that cover was the creation of
biological and chemical weapons that they could use for war.
And as he,
she
made progression,
the project expanded.
And now I'm going to go to the book unit seven 31 by Peter Williams and David
Wallace.
Yeah.
Here we go.
In a few short years each,
she's project had hurdled from relative obscurity to one of top secret and
national importance.
It took two years to construct the establishments.
Hundred and 50 or so buildings,
which included a commendation for thousands of people,
a railway siding,
an incinerator and powerhouse with tall cooling towers and animal house in
airfield,
a large administration building and exercise yard and a strange forbidding,
square shaped building known as roadblock are.
Oh,
the Japanese character row is square in shape,
hence the name of the building.
Although roadblock looked square from the outside.
Hidden from view in the center were two other buildings known as blocks seven
and eight.
Roadblock was the center of bacteria production and disease research block seven
and eight had a more sinister purpose.
You at seven 30 ones bacteriological research division was divided into more
than a dozen squatch each investigating the warfare possibility of a wide
variety of diseases,
plague anthrax,
dysentery,
typhoid pair,
typhoid,
cholera and many other exotic and unknown diseases were studied.
Okay.
Every conceivable facility was given to unit seven 31 so the,
I think that's important because they,
they were getting a lot of money.
This wasn't like a little rogue project that wasn't being supported.
As a matter of fact here.
So two were luxuries lavished on the lifestyle of east.
She's researchers and workers in the remote Manchurian plane at Ping Fan.
A whole biological township grew up,
it was known as Togo village.
So around this unit seven 31 there's a whole village that got created and they
were all living the good life.
By the way,
while Japan is not living with the rest of Japan is,
you know,
getting ready to go to war or at war in various parts of the world and living
lean,
the here,
they're living large.
Okay.
Back to the book,
Togo villagers had plentiful supplies of the best foods at times when people in
Tokyo,
we're starving.
Ping Fan was centrally,
he did against the bitter subzero temperatures of the main cheering winter.
Naturally it had the best sanitation,
including even western style style laboratories.
Okay.
So he took care of his people and his people and he were getting taken care of
building a bacterial bacterial weapon.
He,
she found out was not an easy task.
He and his researchers faced a myriad of problems.
What kind of micro organisms would make a effective biological warfare agent?
Should it have a lethal or incapacitating effect?
Could it be produced in quantity sufficient for wartime employment?
Could these living organisms be kept kept alive through storage and shipment to
their ultimate employment on the battlefield?
What type of munition would be needed to deliver the agent to the target?
What were the technical and military characteristics of such a weapon?
So he started from ground zero trying to figure all this out
as she approached the problem by looking for weapons that could be delivered
from altitude by aircraft causing massive outbreaks of epidemics.
Ever since his trip to Europe play get fascinated.
He,
she and I talked about his travel and this is,
they're talking a little bit about that here.
He knew it would make a deadly weapon if it could be harnessed.
It is highly infectious with an incubation period of three to four days,
sometimes up to a week.
The onset is abrupt with chills,
high fever and extreme weakness.
The eyes red in the face becomes congested and the tongue coded victims can
become maniacally delirious and death may be rapid,
sometimes within one day compared with some bacterial pathogens.
Plague is only moderately infectious,
but more virulent strains can be cultivated.
Okay.
Played could create casualties often out of all proportion to the number of
bacteria disseminated he she deduced therefore that it would make an efficient
weapon said about preparing the most dangerous strains.
And at some point on this podcast we'll talk about the black plague,
which is an epidemic that was insane in Europe.
But when you,
when you,
when you have any knowledge about the black plague and you read about someone
that's looking at it saying,
hey,
this looks like a good idea,
you realize that this is just a sick,
sadistic person.
Plague had another advantage for ICI.
It's origins could be concealed science had not then provided a satisfactory
answer to the age old question of why,
where for how long and how badly a plague epidemic broke out.
So he,
he's just thought,
oh,
this is great.
We can cover it up and play the hits our enemy and we,
we,
you know,
we don't know where it came from.
Okay.
So they are producing this,
they begin to produce this.
So large was the production plant that in the heyday of unit seven 31 it had the
potential for creating sufficient bacteria to kill the world's population
several times over.
Okay.
Now that he,
she could produce plague and other virulent bacteria in sufficient quantities
for warfare.
His next task was to discover how he could deliver his deadly microbes to the
enemy.
And obviously I'm not reading this entire book and,
and there's more detail about the process of getting to breed these bacteria
once they figured out how to breed it.
And now we've got to figure out how to deliver it.
How are we going to attack the enemy with this?
He tries all kinds of different things.
And then finally back to the book.
His,
I had come to rest upon the humble flee as a nature.
So tune war,
this minute insect could be relied upon as the carrier of pestilence
to yield vast quantities of fleas and feed them enormous numbers of rats had to
be caught and bread.
This was the job of unit seven 30 ones.
Animal House run by each.
She's elder brother meet Sewell.
There's like a,
as I was reading this,
there's like this whole image of,
I mean are there,
you just think about the,
the reputation of rats and fleas.
Rats and fleas are just,
they're the worst.
They're the worst,
right?
Yeah.
And,
and it just paints this picture or you just see rats and fleas and this is what
they're breeding.
Yeah.
This could,
this is like a horror movie.
Yeah.
At
back to the book at times of peak production,
members of each,
she's force.
We're required to dress in civilian clothes and go rat catching.
He found a method suitable for weapons use.
Here's a description of the flea factory.
The second division had four special premises for the mass breeding of fleas.
In which a mix temperature,
a fixed temperature of 30 degrees Celsius.
What's maintained metal jars 30 centimeters high and 50 centimeters wide were
used for the bleat breeding of fleas.
Rice husks were poured into the jars to keep the fleas in.
After these preparations,
a few fleas were put into each jar and also a white rap for them to feed on.
The rat was fastened in such a way as to not hurt the fleas.
It's a horror movie,
but
they,
so they're,
they're going through this process of breeding fleas,
breeding rats,
using the rats to feed the fleas and,
and raise the fleet so that they can put these fleas into containers and they're
trying out all different kinds of containers and how to drop them and how to
spread them.
And as they're figuring all that out,
it,
they're doing other things as well.
And it wasn't just rats and fleas there at unit seven 31 back to the book,
hidden from the outside world at the center of unit seven 30 ones roadblock was
the [inaudible] secret of secrets.
So carefully was its existence kept secret that many junior members of unit
seven 31 had no knowledge that it was there at all.
Yeah.
For prisoners to pass through the tunnel entrance was to start a journey of no
return.
Only two things were certain.
Okay.
Agony and death.
Three of the east she brothers and including Taeko Mitsui.
Oh,
and of course the youngest Shiro worked at Ping.
Feign tacky.
Oh,
was the prison commander.
The prisons guards were second or third sons from the east.
She brothers village Kamow.
They were called the special squad tied by bonds of peasant loyalty to their
Lord and Master.
They worshiped him.
Okay.
They called him the honorable Eg or sometimes in reverence war God.
ICI,
most were on educated but all were unswervingly loyal to ensure allegiance.
He,
she paid them extra allowances for their terrible and dangerous duties.
The sort of money sent home for which would support whole families through
difficult times to come even pay for their brothers and sisters.
Educations.
Okay.
No Chemo villager has ever publicly spoken even today about their former life in
Manchuria.
The village is silent.
The ICI family name is still revered for its kindness.
Asked about unit seven 31 older residents will apprehensively reply.
I have nothing to say because it concerns the secrets of the honorable Shiro
[inaudible]
is she based his unit in remote northern Manchuria so he could experiment on
human beings.
They're in what was a police state.
He could be given an uninterrupted supply of human Guinea pigs with a unique
data gained from the human experiments.
He,
she believed Japan could outstrip the rest of the world and developing this new
weapon of war.
No other country would have such accurate details about how [inaudible] epidemic
spread or how to pick it,
protect against them.
Only Japan would fully master the twin fields of biological warfare office and
defense.
Okay.
From the earliest days he,
she appears to have employed human Guinea pigs.
Yeah.
It was performed on prisoners who were sentenced to death at Harbin prison.
Each prisoner was placed in a closely guarded cell.
While the experiments took place after death,
the bodies were burned in an electric furnace to leave no trace.
By 1935 motion pictures of human experiments were customarily being shown to
senior staff officers.
Yeah,
occupied Manchuria and Harban in particular was an ideal location for supply of
human fodder and I should say that.
So it started off,
they would use prisoners that were sentenced to death and that's,
that's where it started.
But the supply wasn't enough and it escalated from there just to just a normal
people.
And here's where it talks about that a little bit.
Back to the book occupied Manchuria and Harban in particular was an ideal
location for supply of human fodder.
Harbin,
a multiracial city of shifting minority groups was a nest of spies.
In addition,
Japan's occupation had brought forth strong resistance from both Chinese
nationalists and Chinese communists as well as indigenous and Mongolians.
There was also a large white Russian population caught in the middle between
communist Russia,
an expansionist Japan
to maintain control in these difficult circumstances was the job of this
Japanese secret service agency called the Toca Mu Keychain and the Ken Pti.
They did so through brutal tactics of fear.
Anyone who voiced opposition to the self declared declared a paradise of men.
Truco was liable to detention.
Many never returned the Japanese secret service guide to the fundamental rules
for interrogating war prisoners reveals that world.
So this is a document which I'm gonna read a couple parts of of of how you
torture people there.
Their process for torturing people
number 62 sometimes depending on circumstances,
it is advantageous to resort to church torture,
torture,
the infliction.
Number 63 torture.
The infliction of physical suffering must be sustained and continued in such a
way that there shall be no other way of relief from suffering except by giving
truthful information.
Torture is advantageous because of the speed with which it is possible with
relative ease to compel persons of week will to give truthful testimony
testimony,
but there is danger that in order to relieve himself from suffering or in order
to please the interrogator,
the person interrogated will on the contrary distort the truth.
In the case of a persons of strong will torture,
may strengthen their will to resist and leave ill feeling against the empire
after the interrogation.
In relation to persons of week,
we'll torture is usually applied in those cases when the person interrogated
does not speak the truth even in the face of evidence.
But there is full reason to suppose that this person will speak.
Frankly,
if torture is applied.
Yeah,
it is necessary to bear in mind that the methods of torture must be such as can
easily be applied as will sustain suffering without rousing feelings of pity
and as will not leave either wounds or scars.
So let's think about that right there.
What they're saying is that the torture has to be so easy to apply,
that the person that's doing the torturer won't feel sorry for him.
Hmm.
However,
in cases where it's necessary to create the apprehension of death,
the harm caused the person interrogated can be ignored,
but this must be done in such a way as to not make it possible to continue,
not make it impossible to continue the interrogation
after the application of torture.
It is necessary to convince the person who has undergone the torture that
torture applied to him was quite a natural measure or to take such measures as
will induce him out of his sense of pride,
sense of honor,
et Cetera,
not to speak about it afterwards.
So that's when you say,
Hey,
look,
we taught you,
you broke and your week and you should be embarrassed about it.
Number 69 nobody must know about this application of torture except the person's
concerned with this.
Under no circumstances must other prisoners know about it.
It is very important to take measures to prevent shrieks from being heard.
Okay?
So they had their methodology,
they had their standard operating procedures.
Okay?
To be a spy or dissident in Manchuria was to risk death by firing squad or
decapitation,
but there wasn't an alternative far worse death at the hands of unit seven 31
unsuspecting and innocent people were also tricked into the clutches of unit
seven 31 somewhere,
Lord,
by the prospect of employment,
young boys,
mothers and children,
even pregnant women were trapped.
Okay,
here's a,
a medical orderly named [inaudible] who carried out checkups on,
and there's a word here [inaudible] and you're going to hear what [inaudible]
says.
This is what they describe.
The people that are being held,
the prisoners inside of unit seven 31 they called them Brutus or Merita
singular.
Right.
Okay.
And here's what the orderly had to say about it.
I started to work for Unit seven 31 at age of 18 in a special section,
which did the press,
the checkups on new prisoners.
We took details of their blood type.
It's pulse and pressure and other things.
Prisoners were all referred to as [inaudible],
which is the Japanese word for a log of wood.
Although when they arrived,
they had cards each with their name,
birthplace,
reason for arrest and age.
We simply gave them a number.
I'm a,
Rita was just a number,
a piece of experimental material.
Okay.
They were not even regarded as human beings.
Most were between 20 and 40 years old.
None were over 50 they seem to know their fate.
We did terrible things.
Okay,
so you can see some obvious dehumanization.
They don't call them people.
They call them logs.
They give them a number,
not a name.
Very standard practice for dehumanization.
Back to the book,
the prison was a vision of hell
through the spy hole cut in the steel doors of each cell,
the plight of the chain where Routas could be seen.
Okay.
Some had rotting limbs,
bits of bone protruding through the skin,
black and by necrosis.
Others were sweating and high fever,
writhing in agony or moaning in pain.
Those who suffered from respiratory infectious coughed incessantly.
Some were bloated,
some emaciated,
and others were blistered or had open wounds.
Many of the cells were communal and infected.
Person would be put in with healthy Marita's to see how easily did diseases
spread.
Okay.
In desperation,
Marucci's would try to practice primitive preventive medicine to escape the
diseases
through these little spy holes,
the most act,
the most acute symptoms of the worst diseases in the world.
We're coldly observed by seven 30 one's a white coated doctors,
okay.
Maroon does were used up at the rate of two to three per day.
The dichotomy between the doctors true vocation and the need to build a
medically based weapon was well and expediently expressed by an individual,
probably she at the initial assembly of unit seven 31 so this is a quote,
our God given mission as doctors is to challenge all varieties of disease
causing microorganisms to block all roads of intrusion into the human body,
to annihilate all foreign matter resident in our bodies and to devise the most
expeditious treatments possible.
Yeah.
However,
the research upon which we are now about to embark is the complete opposite of
these principles and may cause us some anguish,
has doctors.
Okay.
Nevertheless,
I beseech you to Pur pursue this research based on the double medical thrill.
One a scientist to exert effort to probing for the truth in the natural science
and research and into and discovery of the unknown world and to as a military
person to successfully build a powerful military weapon against the enemy.
One young serologists doctor Akimoto sent from the Tokyo Imperial University to
Manchuria bias professor,
we called the horror of discovering the true purpose of an epidemic prevention
and water supply unit.
And here's what he said.
I was very shocked when I arrived and found out about the human experiments.
Okay.
Very few of those scientists,
scientists had a sense of conscious.
Okay.
They were treated,
they treated the prisoners like animals.
The prisoners were the enemy.
They would eventually be sentenced to death.
They thought the prisoners would die,
an honorable death if in the process they contributed to the progress of medical
science.
Yeah,
I was very frightened.
Although my work involve no human experiments.
I wrote my resignation three or four times,
but there was no way to get out.
Okay.
I was told that if I left,
I might secretly be executed.
Okay.
So yeah,
there and I,
this is covered in pretty good depth from the book.
There was like a whole recruiting process to bring the best doctors and
scientists from all the universities in Japan up to Manchuria to work there.
So these young kids are becoming doctors thinking they're going to go out there
and save people.
And the exact opposite happens.
Back to the book.
Syphilis was studied.
Many female Marita's died as unit seven 31 endeavored to solve the venereal
disease epidemics raging through the ranks of imperial Japanese army as its
military hordes Marotta around the Asian continent.
Yeah.
On one occasion,
a pregnant woman was deliberately infected with the disease and when her child
was born,
both were dissected.
Cruel experiments were not confined,
confined to the roadblock.
Five hours from Ping Fan by truck lay Anta proving ground unit seven 30 ones
education division trees chief Lieutenant Colonel Nishi took part in one
experiment.
Here are his comments and experiment in which I participated was performed in
infecting 10 Chinese war prisoners with gas gang green.
Okay.
The object of the experiment was to ascertain whether it was possible to infect
people with gas gang green at a temperature of 20 degrees Celsius below zero.
Yeah.
This experiment was performed in the following way.
10 Chinese war prisoners were tied to steaks at a distance of 10 to 20 meters
from a shrapnel bomb that was charged with gas gang green.
Okay.
To prevent the men from being killed outright.
Their heads and backs were protected with a special metal shield and thick
quilted blankets,
but their legs and buttocks or left on protected.
The bomb was exploded by means of an electric switch and the shrapnel bearing
gas gang green germs scattered all over the spot where the experiment teas,
we're bound.
All the experiment teas were wounded in the legs or buttocks and seven days
later they died in great torment.
Miraculously,
some Ruda has survived all infection experiments developing remarkable
immunities,
but their fate was always the same.
Okay.
Unit seven 31 had many other uses for human fodder,
so they,
they talk about this in the book,
How some people would develop immunity.
Some guys were just super tough,
just tough and in fact there's one where they talk about they,
they finally kill this guy after experiment.
He's a 65 year old guy.
He was just just tough.
He survived all of these different infections,
all of these different diseases,
and they,
they finally,
when they kill him,
they,
they opened him up,
they dissect him and they see that he's got the organs of a 25 year old or
something.
But it didn't matter,
even if you were resistant to diseases,
they had other experiments to do
the education chief Nishi had some other recollections about some of those other
experiments
back to the book with temperatures below negative 20 degrees Celsius,
people were brought out from the detachments prison into the open.
Okay.
Their arms were Baird and made to freeze with the help of an artificial current
of air.
Okay.
This was done until they're frozen arms when struck with a short stick emitted a
sound resembling that which a board gives out when it is struck.
Yeah.
A film was made on this subject too.
Here's another,
yeah.
Account of these do.
So they were,
they were trying to figure out things about frostbite,
frostbite and what people could take because they're going to be fighting up in
the steps of Manchuria in Russia.
They thought they'd be fighting there.
So they had to figure out,
do experiments to figure out how to heal frostbite once it happened and how much
cold someone could take.
Here's a printer that worked there and here's a uh,
account of what he witnessed.
Two naked men were put in an area 40 to 50 degrees below zero and researchers
filmed the whole process until they died.
Okay.
They suffered such agony.
They were digging their nails into each other's flesh.
Okay.
This was military life.
You couldn't say,
I want to do this or that and war,
however good or bad,
the Japanese way is to obey a superior.
It was the same as if the order came from the emperor.
Sometimes there were no anesthetics.
They screamed and screamed,
but we didn't regard the logs as human beings.
They were lumps of meat on a chopping block.
The Japanese way is to obey a superior.
I talk about that all the time.
You got a question?
Yeah.
Continuing detachment.
Seven 31 had a sister unit.
It was called the seven 16 chemical warfare unit.
Tests were carried out in a large cloud chamber.
The size of a telephone box made of thick steel.
It had an agitator in the ceiling connected by large pipes to a gas producing
machine.
Maroon is we're putting a truck tied to a pole and pushed inside some naked
summoned,
full army uniform and some and gas masks.
Seven 31 and five 16 researchers watched them gasp and convulse to their deaths.
Through the chambers reinforced to glass window.
A young mother and her baby were even put to death in this chamber.
She desperately tried to protect her child from the fumes by covering it with
her body.
She died lying on top of her child.
Here's another account from a medical
orderly
about other experiments beyond cold and beyond,
chemical and beyond.
Beyond biological.
Here we get to malnutrition.
I saw malnutrition experiments.
They were conducted by the project team under the technician Yoshi Mirror.
He was a civilian member of unit seven 31 the purpose of the experiments,
I believe,
was to find out how long a human being could survive with just water and
biscuits.
Two Maru does were used for this experiment.
They continuously circled at prescribed course within the grounds of the unit
carrying approximately a 20 kilogram sandbag on their backs.
One come before the other,
but they both ultimately died.
The duration of the experiment was about two months.
Okay.
They only received army biscuits to eat and water to drink so that they would
not have been able to survive for very long.
They weren't a lot of sleep
either.
Okay.
And here's
one of the major general [inaudible] Kawashima and he talks about the fate of
some of the [inaudible] from 500 to 600 prisoners were consigned to detachment
seven 31 annually if a prisoner survived the inoculation of lethal bacteria.
This did not save him from a repetition of the experiments which continued until
death from the infection supervened
the infected people were given medical treatment in order to test various
methods of cure.
They were fed normally and after they had fully recovered.
Okay.
Were used for the next experiment,
but infected with a different kind of germ.
At any rate,
no one ever left this factory alive.
Okay.
Following anatomical study,
the bodies of the dead were burned and the detachments incinerator.
Okay,
so as I said,
there's even if you're just tough as nails,
they're just going to give you a different disease or more disease
and
all pretty horrible and now it gets worse.
Back to the book,
perhaps the greatest horror of unit seven 31 was vivisection
unit seven 31 had two teams of pathologists,
one headed by Dr Ahca,
Modo,
the other by doctor he she cow
anatomical study performed by these squads was not always confined to the dead
pathology Squat Assistant Kiram Zawa saw vivisections
unit seven 31 did work on living human bodies.
He said,
yeah,
to do this work.
Our sentiments were suppressed,
so this is a whole new level we're actually dissecting or vivisect and people
that are alive.
Back to the book,
some doctors are said to have come all the way from Japan just to see such a
dissection.
Laboratory assistants got extra pay called the chemical weapons allowance for
wielding the scalpel during this dreadful war.
Okay.
Blood is said often to spurted all over the ceiling of the dissection room as
certain incisions were made,
limbs of the dying Marita's would flex and jerk involuntary out in voluntarily
as the scalpel entered particular parts of the brain.
Okay.
Oregon's would twitch vigorously after they were thrown into jars.
Of Formalin for preservation.
Okay.
Not only were anesthetics researched but also bizarre surgical experiments
connecting different parts of the body are reported to have been performed.
Okay.
So
yeah,
this is,
this is a horror movie that's actually happening.
You got sewing different parts of the body together.
This is just a horror movie except this is not a movie
and
the
the people that are being referred to as my route has right now our people
back to the book the world and we'll probably never learn of all the grizzly
experiments that took place at unit seven 31 among them.
More pressure experiments similar to those carried out by doctor ratio at Dachau
concentration camp.
Yeah.
Presumably done on behalf of the Japanese air force.
It was an extremely painful method of killing individual place in the unit.
Seven 31 pressure chamber would suffer terrible agony as their eyes first popped
out of their sockets as the I membrane ruptured and later as blood forced its
way out through pores in the skin.
Okay.
Maroon has had their blood siphoned off and replaced with horse blood and plasma
experiments.
Okay.
It was said the number of these poor men,
women and children who became route is were mummified alive and total
dehydration experiments.
They sweated a death under the heat of hot dry fans.
Okay.
At death,
their corpse is weighed only one fifth normal body weight.
Others were electrocuted,
boiled,
alive,
killed and giant centrifuges or died from prolonged exposure to x rays
in all,
some 3000 are said to have been murdered.
Some were just killed off when there was an excess of supply.
They were killed like animals in APP in an Avatar,
every bit of their bodies mercilessly,
mercilessly used up in the name of the terrible medicine of military science.
Now
as he,
she went on with these experiments,
he was,
he got worried about something and this is what he got worried about.
Back to the book.
There was a small but crucial chance that some of his weapons might not work on
American or Anglo Saxon racial groups.
In 1943 researcher Ood Sumi was sent on trips to Inner Mongolia to study the
immunities of Mongolians and other races.
Another had already been sent to a place called moved in,
so mk dons another prison camp.
So he got concerned that as he did these experiments that some diseases affect
different races differently.
And there was some chance that,
oh,
we've,
we'd use this type of bacteria against an Anglo Saxon or a white person.
It might not work.
So we got to,
we got to figure that one out.
Well,
the Japanese had captured Americans and Brits and Australians.
So here we're going to hear it a little bit about the prisoners in Mukhsin.
Okay.
I said is another prison camp.
Back to the book of Warren W welchol
known more familiarly as pappy came from Tulsa,
Oklahoma was a master sergeant with the u s 200 200 coast artillery antiaircraft
regimen on April 9th,
1942 Bhutan fell on May 6th,
so to Corregidor pappy Welchol and 88,000 other Americans and Filipinos were
captured.
Pappy remembers it was the beginning of one of the most dehumanizing experiences
ever perpetrated on humans.
Well and his fellow prisoners had to endure the familiar ill treatment.
The Japanese made it out to prisoners of war,
a proceeding that is understandable only if you'd,
from the Japanese standpoint that to die in battles honorable but to surrender
is to be shamed,
but is also dehumanizing because unknown to him,
he was to become a human Guinea pig in Japan's experimental program as they
sought to build weapons of biological warfare,
Welchol was to spend three years of his life as one of the 1,485 American and
British and Australian and New Zealand prisoners of war who were herded into a
special prison camp in Manchuria at Mukhsin.
And of course,
uh,
they hiked there.
Back to the book,
the root,
the 1000 American prisoners took the and began with what became known as the
Bataan Death March.
We were subjected to beatings,
killings,
forced marches during the heat of the day.
We were deprived of food,
water in any medical attention whatsoever.
Pappy welchol remembered
they were penned in two camps in the Philippines.
Hundreds more died,
both in the camp and the s and from suffocation as more than 100 crammed into
boxcars on the journey from one camp to another.
Then in October of 1942 about a thousand US troops had been singled out and
marched to Manila,
the capital of the Philippines.
They went aboard the Japanese vessel territory,
Maru.
And here's a quote from the moment we,
when a board that hell ship,
they were experimenting on us.
They threw us a board to see how much we could stand in,
how many of us died.
They took us from the tropics to a bitterly cold climate and that took its toll
on us.
They gave us a few crackers and little rice to eat and I feel that it was a
systematic way of beginning to test us to found out to find out how much the
Americans and the British and Australians could endure and that was said by
Greg.
Greg Rodriguez senior now retired from his career as a foreman in Henryetta,
Oklahoma.
Rodrigo's was a private in 59 coast or alternately core us army.
He survived the journey to move din and three years in the camp itself.
Now there's another guy named Robert PD who was a senior British officer and he
was also in prison in moved in and he kept a daily diary or at least he tried to
keep a daily diary and he kept it in code form.
Here's some,
here's some of his entries into his journal.
19 April 43 another Japanese medical investigated investigation started today as
apparently the findings of the first did not meet with approval.
24 may diarrhea is increasing.
25 may waiting for medicine for diarrhea,
which was not forthcoming.
Men were ordered to exercise by playing baseball.
26 may.
Diagnosis of diarrhea consists of running the men around the parade ground.
I saw some of them with bare feet,
those who do not mess their pants or drop from exhaustion or reckoned to be
liars and are told to go back.
A protest has been made and a change is expected in both methods and personnel.
For June 3rd Japanese medical investigation started five June antidisciplinary
inoculation,
one half cc including flesher y eight June,
diarrhea still steadily increasing.
13 June 2nd antidisciplinary shot one cc six August.
Okay.
There are now
208 dead,
so as they're doing these experiments and they've got these dead bodies of
American,
Australian,
British soldiers.
Okay.
They're still trying to utilize them when they're dead to try and learn from
them.
Back to the book,
one morning early in 1943 Frank James was assigned to burial detail.
This is of some of those bodies.
I was pretty sick myself,
but I wouldn't go to the hospital because nobody that went in ever came out.
I went round to the hut and it must have been,
I reckon 340 bodies stacked there.
Each body had a tag attached to its toe.
There were two or three men who I took to be Japanese doctors there.
They were all master 100% all the time they were there,
their faces were covered.
Another fellow and I were told to lift up the bodies and put them on the autopsy
tables.
Then they began to cut them open.
They went deep into the stomach,
the bile,
the small intestine,
and they took what looked like pancreas and lungs.
Okay.
They also operated on the heads and took part of the brain.
So just a horror film,
a horror show
for the prisoners.
The end of their incarceration in Mulkin was quite matter of fact,
and again,
this is a fast forward and it also skips ahead a little bit talking about how,
how the war ended and what that was like.
After days of rumor,
major PDS diary records for August 16th,
1945 or six men were brought into camp this evening and from the fact that they
were smoking more than the regulation distance from an ashtray,
we knew they were not prisoners of war.
Okay.
After an unusually good supper.
All prisoners were released from the guard house.
Then he continues on.
This is on 20 August at about 7:00 PM a small Russian,
a small party of Russian officers arrived and announced that we are now free.
The Russian officer in charge said,
here they are.
Do what you like with them,
cut their throats or shoot them.
It's all the same to me,
but this was translated diplomatically as he says,
he hands them over to you for major PD and the hundreds who had survived the
privations of looped in the victory was there as in every sense
they had no need.
They decided to seek reprisals.
It would have been said the major beneath our dignity.
It would have reduced us to their level.
After all,
they had to live the rest of their lives with what they'd done.
So
the horror show ends and these,
these soldiers that had been tortured and killed,
murdered they,
they decide they're not even going to take revenge because they don't want us.
They don't want to lower themselves to that level.
That's an amazing,
but like I said,
that it skipped ahead.
The war still wasn't over and here we go.
Back to the book.
He,
she expected the final decisive battle would take place between June and
September,
1945 when America attempted to land on Japan proper Okinawa,
Japan's own island Bastian fell in June the month before Germany had
surrendered.
Russia urged by Britain and America at Yalta turned their attention to Manchuria
for forces swelled on both sides of the Soviet Manchurian border.
As millions of troops remained at standoff point,
Tanaka's flea factory was expanded and given more staff with 4,500 flea breeding
machines and operation.
100 million insects could be produced every few days.
He,
she planned to breed 300 kilograms,
approximately 1 billion plague fleas in the runup toward special training
courses in flea breeding.
We're set up at Ping Fein in June and sub unit members ordered back afterwards
to establish their own production basis to propagate plague cultures and to feed
the fleas.
Rats were needed in their thousands.
Yamato ordered every land unit of the quantifying quantong army to track rats.
Cora Sal was new conveyor system and again I'm throwing names in here that are
explained with a lot more detail in the book.
That's why you buy the book and read the book so you can get the full picture.
Kurosawa's new conveyor system was working round the clock,
producing plague typhoid,
cholera and anthrax organisms,
which were sufficient if correctly dispersed to in fact half the planet.
Okay,
between midnight and 1:00 AM on the morning of August 9th after he rose Shima
had been devastated by the atomic bomb.
The Soviet army swept across the border into Manchuria and Korea with a massive
force of one and a half million men,
5,500 tanks and 5,000 airplanes.
The tongue army was thrown into panic.
Confusion broke loose that day or the day after.
Yamato ordered the destruction of units seven 31 and 100 again.
Seven 31 we've been talking about 100 was another one of these parallel units
that was doing the same type of stuff on nearby.
Sapper unit was ordered to blow up Ping fans,
main headquarters,
the units personnel,
or to destroy all evidence and be evacuated.
Decel Seoul in Korea,
a second bomb was yet to be dropped.
The Maga Saki.
So here the wars obviously turning,
we dropped the bomb and they go to cover their tracks.
Completely destroy everything,
destroyed the buildings,
destroy all the records,
destroy everything.
Okay.
And when I say everything,
I mean everything here we go back to the book at Pink Fan.
Maru does,
we're the first to be destroyed.
Okay.
Members of the five 16 chemical warfare unit gas.
The Maroon is by throwing flasks of toxic chemicals into their cells.
600 local Manchurian in Chinese laborers who worked at the Jaga Sour plant
disease farm and elsewhere.
A Ping Fang.
We're machine gunned potassium cyanide poison was also put into the Maroon is
breakfast food.
Yeah.
So they're just trying to,
like I said,
destroy everything and make it like it didn't happen.
And as they wrap this up,
the rest of units,
seven 31 expecting a few left behind for final clearing up assembled on the 13th
and 14th at the shunting yard each.
She made a formal speech extolling the memory of unit seven 31 and it's diligent
research as if and mockery of him.
It was interrupted by the sound of a prison exploding.
Okay.
Members were issued vials of poison.
He,
she had originally wished every branch member in all families in Togo village to
commit suicide,
but this proposal,
this proposal was met,
met the violent disagreement of Major General Kikuchi seven 30 ones research
chief.
Nonetheless,
some took their lives without orders from eg.
Three thought fished all kill themselves.
Got a little resistance there.
I would,
I would have fought that.
Okay.
Kikuchi perhaps would have provided more resistance.
Against the behavior that they were occurring to you,
not just to,
you just want to protect himself here at the end.
Hey,
I'm not going to question anything as long as it doesn't affect me.
Right.
Yeah.
That's what that is.
On August 15th the emperor broadcast Japan's defeat and surrender.
It had never occurred to Isciu that Japan might give in.
Okay.
He had to confirm the broadcast before believing it such was the shock that
according to one account he,
she was seen in a listless condition utterly falling
that day in the late afternoon units,
seven 31 train arrived at Hinz king there.
On the following night,
he,
she made a final address to the,
to his Ernst wild troops.
He swore them to life in the shadows for the rest of their lives and the light
of the candle held by an aide to Camp II.
She ordered them never to speak of their military past,
never to take official positions in the future and never again to contact each
other.
It is a promise that some have kept to this day.
The pathetic end of Japan's once mighty biological warfare effort was to let
loose thousands of infected rats in the neighborhood of Ping Fan.
It caused a local plague epidemic,
which claim to many innocent lives into the summer of 1946 at unit at a hundred
a handful of infected horses were freed after the surrender.
Yeah.
You know,
you hear that argument about the,
about the dropping of the atomic bombs.
And the common argument is always it would have cost massive amounts of lives on
both sides,
Americans and Japanese,
because the Japanese were going to fight to the death and the Americans were
going to kill them all.
And so the best thing to do is like,
okay,
we dropped the atomic bomb.
So this just kind of makes that a closed deal in my mind.
You know,
you got people that are trying to,
they got enough enough biological weapon treated in fact half the world.
So,
and again,
jumping forward in this book,
get the book so that you can get the whole story.
But there's a,
a massive investigation that takes place to find out what's going on.
There's little leaks.
They,
they catch wind of a little of it,
but not a lot of it.
And at one point they're interrogating each sheet.
And here's east,
she,
he,
she denied any involvement.
Our work was to protect soldiers.
He said,
did anyone else concerned themselves with biological warfare against crop
plants?
I do not know.
Replied each sheet.
His interrogator made no effort to pursue the matter.
Thompson,
a veterinarian by training turned the questions of biological warfare against
animals.
We did not do any experiments on log.
Large animals said he she.
We use small animals as test animals.
Besides we had no veterinarians.
What field tests were made with the plague organism?
He asked,
due to the danger of it,
there were no field experiments with that organism.
There were a great many field mice and Manchuria and it would have been
dangerous to conduct field experiments with plague because the field mice would
very easily carry the organisms and start an epidemic.
We conducted the experiments with plague in the laboratory,
set each she what kind of experiments?
Thompson inquired.
We put rats in cages inside the room and sprayed the whole room with plague
bacteria.
This was to determine how the rats became infected,
whether through the eyes,
nose,
mouth,
or through the skin.
What did you find out the test results were not too favorable.
We usually got 10% infection,
by which way?
That was the total said he she misunderstanding the question.
What route was most effective?
Thomson repeated through the nose,
said he,
she also through an open wound,
so they're interrogating.
He's being pretty,
he's lying,
he's covering up.
But there's,
there's a twist that we're going to see unfold here and I'll explain it a little
bit so it makes sense as it comes forth.
The twist in this story is that the Cold War was about to start.
The Cold War was now starting and America,
these experiments that had taken place and knowledge had been gained through
this,
through these evil experiments.
Well,
America looked at the knowledge and recognized or saw that there could be
knowledge that they didn't,
that we didn't have,
that America didn't have and and decided,
let's try and get this knowledge.
Now,
one of the problems is,
and again this is going to unfold,
but I'll give a brief synopsis of it.
One of the problems is if you charge someone with war crimes and you put them on
trial,
well you've got to stay with their own what the war crimes that they committed.
And if you say that the war crimes were committed were these experiments with
chemical and biological weapons,
then people are going to know
what the results of the experiments were and that means the knowledge is going
to be out there and the knowledge could fall into the hands of people that we
were now looking to be facing in another war,
which ended up being the Cold War.
Luckily not a full war.
So
that's how this,
that's how this story continues to unfold.
Back to the book,
there's no question that he,
she has an India as an individual and many of his associates were guilty of
serious war crimes.
As a lieutenant general,
he,
she was an ICI undoubtably possessed sufficient high military rank to be
classified as a class a war criminal.
He was the top of the tree in his own field.
His actions as the head of unit seven 31 qualified him as a criminal on many
accounts.
Not only was biological warfare considered extra legal by most countries,
but issue is also guilty of outrageous conventional war crimes.
He had carried out calculated human experimentations on prisoners of war,
a conventional war crime that had long been prescribed in the manuals of
military law of every major power he'd carried out similar research against
innocent civilians,
clearly a crime against humanity.
These,
she had taken his biological weapon out of the research laboratory and used it
in the field.
He had sought autonomy and independence of action for his biological warfare
forces throughout the war zones.
He had done nothing to restrain the conduct of his subordinates.
So this guy is as guilty as they come.
They they are was other
other events that took place that were equally bad.
And here we go.
Some tribunals were held in China,
the Philippines and the Pacific islands,
but most a total of 314 cases were held at Yokohama.
Japan.
At these courts,
a sufficient number of medical atrocity cases were heard for them to be
considered as a special category.
The most well known and worst case presented by legal section at Yokohama
concerned the fate of captured American flyers held by the Japanese western army
in Kyushu after April,
1945 the appalling experiments to which they had been subjected included
vivisection and the substitution of seawater for their blood.
Okay.
For this gross act of barbarism on August 27th,
1948 the nine Japanese involved were convicted and sentenced either to be hanged
or to serve life in prison.
Mint.
Okay.
One professor,
he,
she yama of Kishu University committed suicide in prison.
So
clearly they had the attitude of like,
we're going to get some of these guys that conducted experiments and that's
exactly what should it should happen.
And this was a much smaller number
of people that were tortured and killed and uses human experiments than what was
used it at seven 31
continuing on Cold War,
tensions had been increasing throughout 1946 the desire to meet out stern
justice at the Tokyo trial was increasingly subsumed if found in conflict with
the interests of national security.
Japan was in the front line.
So to now was biological warfare on August 24th,
1946 Washington cabled MacArthur ordering him to protect intelligence,
especially scientific,
which might jeopardize America's national security.
It red under present circumstances,
intelligence relating to research and development in the field of science and
war material should not be disclosed to nations other than the British
Commonwealth.
Okay.
Biological Warfare Intelligence seems by this time to become too much too
sensitive to be brought into the glare of massive of a massive international
trial throughout 1946 in both Russia and America appear to have been reluctant
to reveal their hands in Japan.
America appears to have taken some extra precautions to prevent information from
falling into Soviet hands.
Okay,
so you can see how it's unfolding.
One of these,
again,
one of these senior officers that is talked about deeply in the book,
but I didn't discuss too too much.
His name was NATO.
Okay.
And here's a quote from NATO.
We want to cooperate,
okay.
And we owe it to the general headquarters,
but we have a responsibility to our friends.
We took an oath never to divulge information on human experiments.
We are afraid to,
some of us will be prosecuted as war criminals.
We do not know how much others will be willing to give us.
If you can give us documentary immunity,
probably we can get everything.
The subordinates,
not the section chiefs know all the details.
If we contact someone who is a communist,
he is liable to tell the Russians.
Okay.
The Japanese were given insurances that war crimes would not be involved.
Macarthur send a five again,
fast forward from Macarthur said a five part radio message to Washington showing
the extent of his knowledge.
It's clear from part five they have the whole,
the whole message in the book.
It is clear from part five of the message that Macarthur favored gaining the
biological warfare technical information by offering.
The asserts is that data would not be in ployed at war crimes trials
and here's the she.
I will not reveal the information to the Russians.
Yeah,
can see how this is unfolding.
This is like one of those horrible,
when a crime gets committed in for whatever little technicality people are
getting off,
that's exactly what's going on.
And you can hear it on folding.
And I mean,
does national security Trump the,
it's almost like an ego move,
right?
It's almost like an ego move.
You're gonna make these guys pay.
It's also a morality move and it's a justice.
It's a,
I guess it's beyond ego and beyond route.
It's justice.
These guys were criminals,
these guys per did heinous things to other human beings and they should pay and
is as strong as that case is.
It,
it didn't seem to hold up to the case of national security.
We want to have this information,
not that we were going to use it.
Yeah.
But
we better have it better to have it and not need it than need and not have.
It's better to have it yourself and not let your enemy habit,
which is the Russians at this point.
Yeah.
So that's where the decisions getting made.
So you got to kind of consider what's more important like this justice.
Yeah,
that's exactly the question.
And answers pretty clear what the,
what the answer is is safety,
right?
The,
I mean,
security I got to,
you can get all the justice.
Yeah,
you can get all the justice you want,
but then it was going to create some serious problems in the future.
It's Kinda like,
you know,
is it worth it?
Yeah.
And here's what she talking some more.
I cannot give detailed technical data.
All the records were destroyed.
I never did know many details and I've forgotten what I knew.
I can give you general results I've never heard of onto that's another,
uh,
base that they used until I returned to pink fan in 1945 I did not visit the
location.
I am responsible for all that went on at Ping Fan.
I'm willing to shoulder all responsibility.
Neither my superiors or my subordinates had anything to do with issuing
instructions for experiments.
If you ask me specific questions,
I can tell you general results.
I am wholly responsible for paying fan.
I do not want to see any of my subordinates or superiors get in trouble for what
occurred.
If you will give me documentary immunity for myself,
superiors,
subordinates and subordinates.
I can get you all the information for you.
So He's,
he's making a deal.
He's making deals and look,
I'm responsible for everything.
And what he's doing is saying,
look,
I'm responsible for everything and if you give me immunity,
I'll get you all the information you want.
Hmm.
He's actually a good move.
It's a good move on his part because he says I'm responsible for everything.
Even if they say,
no,
we don't take a deal and we're going to hang you.
He's still,
he's still trying to protect as many as many of his people as he can up and down
the chain of command.
Yeah.
The advisability of complying with issues,
bargain war crimes,
immunity in written form in exchange for scientific data was to occupy some of
Washington's most senior minds throughout the summer of 1947 he,
she continued Masuda,
Kaneko and NATO,
whom you say,
you know,
can give you a lot of information.
I would like to be hired by the United States as a biological warfare expert in
preparation for the war with Russia.
I can give you the advantage of my 20 years research and experience.
I have given a great deal of thought to tactical problems in the defense against
biological warfare.
I have made studies on the best agents to be employed in various regions and in
cold climates.
I can write volume of the ball,
biological warfare,
including the little fault of strategic and tactical employment.
God,
this Guy Scumbag,
so it continues and open back to the book and an open admission about human
experimentation.
Allegations about the,
the use of biological warfare even hints about the connection between units
seven 31 and a member of the Japanese imperial family were all contained in the
files of legal case three 30 by the middle of 1947 yeah.
How did this come about and why was nothing be done being done about the file's
contents?
So this is getting shut down.
That's what's happening.
Now.
Here's the sort of the more
official opinion back to the book on balance.
The sub committee felt it was desirable to avoid a war crimes prosecution.
And here's what they said.
Since it is believed that the USSR possesses only a small portion of this
technical information,
and since any war crimes trial would completely reveal such data to all nations,
it is felt that such publicity must be avoided in interests of defense and the
security of the United States.
It is believed,
it is believed also that war crimes prosecution of ICI and his associates,
which serve to stop the flow of much additional information of a technical and
scientific nature.
It is felt that the use of this information as a basis for war crimes evidence
would be a grave detriment to Japanese cooperation with the United States
occupation forces in Japan.
So there you hear the decisions getting made and that's the way it went.
And in the end,
going back to the book,
No member of unit seven 31 was called before any British or American military
tribe tribunal to account for war crimes.
None of them.
Well
actually not by any British or Americans because the Russians,
they still went after him and they,
and one,
they went after him,
then they got some of them,
they,
they made America look bad and they had a big trial.
And here's the,
the State Council and the state councils name was Smirnoff.
And here we go.
Back to the book smear.
Nofx spelled out a message intended for the ears of an audience.
Thousands of miles from the courtroom.
These men,
he,
she and the rest.
Now you,
she wasn't a part of this trial,
but he,
she and the rest enjoy the protection of those reactionary forces in the
imperialist camp who are themselves dreaming of a time when they will be able to
hurl upon mankind.
Loads of TNT atomic bombs and lethal bacteria.
The accused received the sentences as follows and then they listed these guys
for that various,
uh,
soldiers and civilians that served in some of these biological warfare
experimentation centers.
They got 25 years,
20 years,
18 years,
15 years,
12 years,
10 years.
Two years.
Three years.
Okay.
But again,
those sentences don't include he,
she or the other main players at unit seven 31 cause they got kind protected,
not even kind of,
they are protected by America in exchange for their information.
Sort of in response to everything that was going on there.
On December 27th,
1941 the following story appeared in the New York Times datelines Tokyo.
No Knowledge.
Macarthur says General Macarthur,
General Douglas Macarthur is headquarters said today.
There were no known cases in which Japanese she used American prisoners in germ
warfare experiments.
The headquarters added that the Japanese had done some experiments with animals,
but that there was no evidence they had ever used human beings.
As far as is known here,
no Americans held prisoner by the Japanese sent mucked in,
ever accused their captors of having used them as Guinea pigs in biological
warfare tests.
So that's all not true.
That's all not true.
Back to the book to this day,
Russia has allowed itself to Baskin feelings of more moral superiority over
America and not without some justification in respect of the way it brought it's
unit seven 31 criminals to justice.
So just that's the way,
that's the way it flushed out.
Now
this,
you might think that's a little disturbing.
This is equally disturbing.
This is just horrible.
Back to the book.
After the war,
most of the scientists of units,
seven 31 prospered.
Yeah.
Much is explained by the clear complicity on the part of the United States
authorities in the war crimes of unit seven 31 did it attachments,
civilian researchers and other associated scientists were quite free to return
to academia.
Okay.
And it goes through this lit,
this multiple page list of,
of guys that went on to work at the research institute for Natural Resources
Chief.
And he and another guy was chief research section at a pharmaceutical company.
Um,
doctor each she cow once a pathologist at unit seven 31 who had brought home
within thousands of human pathological samples,
became a professor at a university in 1944 a position he held throughout the
1960s and seventies.
He eventually became president of the university's medical school,
the local newspaper once plan to award him with a metal for his contribution to
society.
But after students who knew of his wartime record objected,
the ward was canceled.
So these guys carried on another guy,
professor of
show a university or pharmacological,
another professor of bacteria logically at Kyoto University.
The list goes on
on,
on doctor [inaudible] Yoshimura who directed units seven 31 to frostbite
experiments.
Literally freezing people to death,
became a faculty member at the Kyoto Prefectural Medical College in the 1950s
and later it's president.
And
like I said,
that list goes on and on and on.
And of course we still haven't heard about east yet.
The mastermind behind this whole thing.
Here we go back to the book,
he,
she inherited much of a family's property in came Oh village.
Cause if you remember Kamal villages where they bring all these prison guards
from their home village so that they'd get the complete loyalty from him.
So he inherited much of the properties,
family,
the family property and came,
Oh village.
His two elder brothers,
Takeo and Mitsui [inaudible] were childless.
Unlike Shiro who fathered six children TKO units.
Seven 31 special prison squad leader eventually died of liver cancer and Koby
the city wants his second wife had come
Mitsui [inaudible] who wants supervise the the units.
Animal House outlived his younger brother's Shiro but was unable to work after
the war and lived on money gained by selling his country property which Solo
Mitsu and take Yale and their eldest brother terrail who had been killed in the
Russo.
Japanese war during Japan's Meiji period are buried in the ICI family cemetery
at Chemo on August 17th,
1958 13 years after the end of the war in the back room of a stone mason shop
near Thomas Cemeteries Tokyo each.
She made his first and apparently only postwar appearance before assembled
junior members of his former unit.
He reminisced about the early days of unit seven 31 in a speech reportedly still
rich and xenophobia and elite Ism II.
She described how his unit was to have been the salvation of Japan,
a country then encircled by the west,
scientifically impro impoverished,
yet spiritually rich.
He apologized for their suffering since the end of the war,
but urged his audience to remain proud of the memory of units seven 31
then here's a little part of his,
what he said,
it was an order that we could have precious human material that the unit seven
31 was set for the saving of the nation
national circumstances.
We're not permitting,
unfortunately we did not achieve our aims.
So even after all that,
even after all that,
even looking back after 13 years after the end of the war,
he's looking back and still has the same mindset and that mentality is hard to
understand and I want to shed a little bit of light on that mentality.
Yeah.
And do that through some,
uh,
personal accounts of what happened at unit seven 31.
And that's from this other book.
It's called unit seven 31 testimony.
Then let's go to this book that I think these make it pretty clear where this
mentality comes from.
So
this account is from a captain in the Japanese imperial army named [inaudible],
Kajima Tec,
Eo.
And here we go.
Perhaps there are some people here and,
and by the way,
most of these accounts are from an exhibition that went around Japan,
kind of explaining what happened and people would come to this exhibition.
Then they would capture if someone was involved in unit seven 31 or someone
remembered her,
someone had a story about it,
they would capture their account.
And that's what this book has a lot of from this expert that this exhibition
that they did,
I think it was in the mid 1990s at,
they did this exhibition.
So this particular person that was showed up at this exhibition,
he was a captain and the Japanese army,
his name is [inaudible].
And here's what he said.
Perhaps there are some people here at this unit seven 31 exhibition who think
that this was all there was to Japan,
Japanese aggression at the time unit seven 31 was merely one segment of the dark
shadow of Japan's aggression.
And I would like to tell of my experience in this,
and I think this is why I pulled this one specifically because this talks about
where this came from,
where this mentality came from,
that he,
she had to the end.
We were born and raised in a society of empiricism.
A person's absolute responsibility above the army and government was to the
emperor.
The emperor was a living deity.
The emperor's command was supreme and controlled the entire country.
We were told how we must serve the emperor,
how we should behave toward our parents,
how should we,
we should behave quarter teachers and how we should behave toward our siblings.
We were taught that Japan is a sacred country,
that the people of Japan are a superior race,
that the people of China,
Korea,
Southeast Asia and Russia were all inferior races and the superior race must
govern them and by doing so we would bring them happiness.
This was the cause to which Japan must devote itself
and then he goes on.
Again,
I'm not reading the entire thing,
but you have to get the book to get these entire accounts.
Soon after we went into service,
we were given training to get our courage up.
We were ordered to watch beheadings.
Chinese were made to sit by a hole in the ground and the seasoned soldiers would
cut their heads off.
Okay.
Blood spurted up from the neck into the air and the bodies would roll into the
holes.
Then we had bay in that practice.
Okay.
Victims had their hands tied behind them around a tree and were used as band net
targets.
Yeah.
We had to watch this as part of our training.
This was a shock to me and for two or three days,
food would not pass through my throat.
What?
Two years later,
I became an officer in charge of a platoon and with about 25 men under me.
Okay.
Later I became a company commander with 151 men,
and that meant that if I didn't build a strong platoon and a strong company,
I would fall behind,
and so I to tested the courage of the soldiers under me by using Chinese
prisoners.
This was normal training in the Japanese army.
When we were not involved in major operations,
we would go out into our own immediate area on continuous three day operations
to see if there were any enemy around.
On such occasions we stole tortured and slaughtered people.
The Chinese had a saying about us that Japan had a threeway complete policy
burned,
completely killed,
completely and pillaged completely.
Yeah.
Yet when we were doing those things,
we had no sense of guilt or of doing anything wrong.
It was for the emperor
for the country,
so that's how they're raised and that's how you get end up with someone like he,
she that goes through all that and still remains loyal even after defeat still
remains loyal to the deposed emperor
and here's an army doctor.
Okay,
named Yuasa.
Ken,
this is not easy for me to speak about,
but it is something I must confess
what I did was wrong.
It is also true that it was forced on me by the government,
but that does not reduce the size of my crime.
It is something that happened a long time ago,
but those who are not taught about the war are ill educated.
The Japanese armor army went to ponder and steel materials and to kill
Japan wanted iron,
coal and provisions and the army drove into the mountains to prosecute the war.
Okay.
At the time,
the Japanese used derogatory terms for the Chinese like Chinaman and Chink and
looked at them with contempt.
When I was a child,
we were told to despise the Chinese,
despise the Koreans.
It's all right to conquer them.
We have become elite and should join with the Americans and British and conquer
Asia.
I hated Warren killing,
but around middle school and into college,
I began to think that such ideas were unavoidable.
People were driven into a life which human qualities in which human qualities
were lost.
Okay.
The soldiers outlet for frustrations was the brothel of the comfort women.
Any means was resorted to in order to raise one's rank and keep up the authority
of the country.
Okay.
And in the Army hospital,
we practiced vivisection
living persons are good for the scalpel practice.
So people were brought in
one day soon after I started at the assignment,
the hospital had told us,
today we will have surgery practice.
I was startled.
It was an order.
There was no getting out of it.
Normally we dissected people who had died of such diseases as typhoid fever,
dysentery,
and tuberculosis.
Now we were being taken to the dissection room for a different type of exercise.
Soldiers came along as observers.
Okay.
Everything started with a signal from the hospital had one Chinese had big fi's
and walk slowly and calmly.
He laid down and had no sign of fear,
no stress on his face.
He was composed.
Someone else used him for surgery practice.
I went over and pushed the other one onto the operating table.
Okay.
I had no feeling of apology or of doing anything bad.
Yeah.
The farmer was resigned to his fate and he lowered his head and walked forward.
I didn't want to get my clothes dirty from him.
I wanted to look sharp.
He went down as far as the operating table,
but didn't want to lie down.
A nurse using broken Chinese told him we're using ether.
It won't hurt.
So lie down.
She gave me a wry smile
when she said that
she had been working there for a long time and when I happened to meet her again
much later and asked her about it,
she didn't remember.
She was handling so many vivisections.
It was routine.
People who repeat evil acts do not remember them.
There is no sense of wrongdoing.
War means this.
Also,
war is not just shooting.
In order for Japan to win,
all the Chinese were made prisoners.
Women's bellies were cut.
Open homes were burned.
If you couldn't do this,
then you weren't a loyal soldier of the emperor.
Even if one despises an act,
one must bear it.
From there,
a person becomes accustomed to it.
We all received practiced.
It was normal to smile at this.
The crimes committed during our aggressive wars are forgotten.
Gone from memory at the time they were considered right.
So the surgery began.
The man was given ether and dissected.
His appendix was so small that it was like looking for a burrowing worm.
I had to cut and search repeatedly.
The blood flow was stopped.
Nerves were cut,
bones were cut with a saw and a tracheotomy was performed.
Blood and air escape from his body.
The blood came foaming up.
Practice time was two hours.
The man died and his body was thrown into a hole and buried.
That was my first crime.
After that,
it was easy.
Eventually I dissected 14 Chinese.
I also saw vivisections.
Once I saw about 40 doctors gathered,
there was a man bound and squatting.
The guard asked the doctors,
are you ready?
Okay.
And the prisoner was laid out without anesthetic to cuts were made down his
belly.
The victim made a few gasps.
The dissection was a botch and he died soon.
I saw four people dissected that way.
Okay.
It is said that there are,
that there were 20 million victims of the war in China,
but only 10 to 20% of these were killed in gunfire exchange.
Most non resisting old people,
women and children were captured and slaughtered.
Prisoners of war could not taken to the front or allowed to escape,
so they were killed in the manner of the rape of Nan King.
Okay.
Those who were a part of it do not come forward to tell the people how it was.
Why?
Because the Japanese had forgotten all about it.
Everybody's forgotten.
They did things and got metals and they don't think they did anything worse than
kicking a dog.
Okay.
They weren't bothered because they never considered it a dreadful thing to take
a scalpel and cut open a living person.
Okay.
This'll be the last
piece of testimony that I read
and this was a soldier that was attached to unit seven 31
named O'hara Tuckey Yoshi,
and he said I joined the cavalry
from my home in 1939 in April of that year I was stationed in northeast China.
Then in March,
1942 I was transferred to unit seven 31
I did not know anything about that unit.
My first duty was taking care of domesticated animals such as sheep,
goats,
horses,
and cows.
I assisted in researching the diseases that affect these animals.
I saw tests in which Maru to were tied to crosses in a large circle.
As planes flew over and dropped bacteriological bombs in the area surrounded by
the crosses.
Their legs were chained and their bodies tied tightly.
We observed the tests from a distance of about 200 meters.
I had the job of cleaning up and disinfecting after the experiments and
gathering debris lying around.
I want people who come to this exhibition to tell their children and
grandchildren that there is nothing more stupid and fearful
than warm.
I want people to tell their children and grandchildren that there is nothing
more stupid and more fearful than war.
Nothing more stupid and fearful than war.
And I think that's a good quote to end this except for it is wrong.
It is wrong because as stupid and as fearful and as reprehensible as war is,
there is something worse than war.
Okay.
And that is allowing this kind of evil to exist.
Yeah.
As bad as warriors and war is awful,
war is hell.
And I have said that over and over again as have many others,
but there are worst things than war.
Things like unit seven 31
okay.
Things like the Nazi concentration camps,
things like the rape of Nan King.
There are things that are worse than war and there are times when war is not
only justified,
but it is a moral obligation.
And I do not say that lightly.
Okay.
But when evil and when darkness and when malevolent and demonic spirits rise to
power,
they must be stopped.
Okay.
And the responsibility for that lies within all of us everyday to do our best,
to do our best,
to move the world away from the darkness and the demons that linger inside men's
minds.
A move the world toward the light
and toward what is good.
And
I think that is all I've got for tonight.
So
Echo Charles,
let me think while I decompress a little bit.
If you could talk about ways for the crew here to move towards the light.
I'm going to try.
I know,
I know.
And if you think about,
okay,
originally
when we started getting into these kinds of podcasts that
touched upon some very heavy,
some very disturbing subject matter.
That was,
that was where the whole sort of x,
let's call it extended closing to the show began.
Yeah.
Kind of.
Good.
Just and,
and I remember like,
I remember like the first time I said to you like,
hey man,
you just talk for a little while.
Yeah.
I need a break over here.
That's how we ended up with this,
this thing.
Yeah.
But then the interesting thing people would say,
hey,
thanks for doing that because you're not the only one that needs to decompress
after you hear this freaking crap.
Yeah.
Actually you hear about this just heinous,
evil.
Yeah.
That really happened.
We need a little break.
We need a little Echo Charles here
too,
you know?
Yeah.
That's,
that's rough.
Where you,
you know,
you go from vivisection,
you know what if you were like,
hey,
all right,
that's all I got for tonight.
Yeah.
Then you kind of are,
you turned off,
you go into,
I don't know,
work or whatever,
whenever you listened to it,
go to bed.
Oh no,
that's,
that came out with,
um,
with one 21,
one 22 and one 23 with Louie polar and we'll chesty puller Louie polar and then
Jake Schick.
I wasn't going to do,
I said to myself,
I can't do one 21 and one 22 and just leave one 22 out there in the world by
itself.
I needed Jake Schick,
my brother to come on and like show that you can get through that,
you know?
And so this is kind of the same thing,
you know,
I just can't like walk off.
Yeah,
yeah.
Mike drop and then,
yeah,
you guys deal with it.
No,
no.
We're going to deal with it together.
That's what we're going to have echo Charles to help us deal with it.
I'll come back little bit,
little bit,
little bit trite tiny camp.
Forget.
I mean,
it's,
you're not going to forget that,
you know,
anyway,
just like,
you can't forget miss shitty season.
You can't forget the repoting king,
I'll know thing.
So you're going to remember but can't forget them.
Eli masker.
Yeah,
the harsh.
I mean just,
it's,
it's crazy.
Yeah.
But yeah,
man.
Oh far be it from our intention to leave you with bad feelings that last
we want,
I've said this before,
right?
We want you to remember but not dwell.
Yes.
Right.
I think that's important.
You know,
are you dealing with loss?
I mean,
I talk about that a lot when you're dealing with loss.
Yeah.
You always want to remember the people you've lost,
but you can't dwell on it.
Yeah.
And you always want to remember the rape and Nan,
you always want to remember machete season.
You always want,
want to remember unit seven 30 when you always want to remember man's search for
meaning.
You always want to remember me Lai massacre.
You want to remember those things because they're real and they happen and they
can happen again if we let them.
Yeah.
We can't dwell on them because there's,
there's,
cause you know what we one good one and goodwill when,
yeah,
that's what I'm thinking.
Yeah.
Fully.
You know how there's this movie called something about us in a Pete acumen 17
maybe.
There's literally no possible way I've seen this movie sending people.
I've never seen it.
I've seen the,
the,
oh,
he's like completely like psycho sick,
disturbing.
Yeah.
Weirdo scientist guy.
So
you know,
I can't help but kind of think it's when you said this isn't a movie,
this really happened.
And that's really the hard part when you really start to think about death.
Just like how we're sitting here right now,
what's easy things?
What's really hard is you know,
you,
you picture the mother in a gas chamber with her baby and you,
you can't just picture up mother.
Yeah.
You can't just picture a child.
You have to like picture a mother and a child that,
you know,
you need to put that in.
You need to picture someone that you,
cause you can't,
you can't make,
that connection may be saying a mother and a child that that doesn't,
that doesn't bring it together for you.
You actually have to picture someone you know and their kid being that's what
you need to picture of being fourth.
Cause that's what those people were.
They were people,
they were people would alive in there.
I had hopes and dreams and all those things and they got put into a gas chamber
to see how long they could last without a gas mask.
That's what you have to picture.
Yeah.
It makes the point for sure.
Well,
oh,
here's the moral question.
Okay.
You know how like some of these doctors and scientists,
they went on to be prosperous,
you know,
after this deal.
And they obviously,
I mean apparently some of them did some really good work where they're getting
like awards and whatnot.
And you know what,
speaking of this,
I was thinking about this because another really dark book that we covered on
here was an ordinary men in which ordinary men talked about the,
the police,
the Nazi police that went from being normal.
Guys that were middle aged hadn't been indoctrinated in the Nazi way of life as
children.
They got kind of like swept along with the rest of the Germans and they ended up
committing these heinous acts and murdering thousands and thousands of of Jews.
But what's interesting about that,
so in that story,
it's normal guys going evil in this story,
these evil guys that did evil things,
they come out the other side and kind of like go normal.
It's just
so did they,
didn't they get kind of,
they got forced into it though,
right?
Remember they were like,
Hey,
you got to do this or you die.
Did get,
well,
not really.
If you remember in,
in ordinary men,
their commander actually in the beginning is like,
hey,
if you want it,
if you don't want to do this,
go home.
Right?
No,
no.
I mean the,
the Japanese or Japanese 31 remember?
There's definitely some guys getting forced into it.
Yeah.
So you hear,
so here's the moral question.
It's like,
okay,
of course,
you know,
these guys committed crimes regardless of of,
the surrounding circumstances.
They committed these crimes with factual and then they kind of get away and then
they get into normal society and they're,
and they don't get punished.
Right.
Perceive like no justice,
no justice.
But so here's the moral questions.
So is it,
did they make up even a little bit further crime by doing good in the future,
even though they didn't get punished?
Like did they make up for it or is it more of a crime because they got to do
good stuff.
They got to get awards and they got to be prosecutors in the prosperous yeah.
And they shouldn't have
these are what if you look at it from the perspective of like,
Hey,
let's look at them.
Hold.
So there's,
there's two ways I'm going to say I'm going to stages for you.
Look at it holistically from like,
okay,
here's this person.
Let's look at it from my,
from Jockos perspective.
Here's this person.
They did these horrible things,
but now they've kind of got back on track and they've put their life together
and,
and that's,
that's a positive thing.
And they've,
even if you can't make up for that whole crime,
at least you're chipping away at some of the horrible things you did and
replacing it with something good.
And,
and you can see where people come to the conclusion that like,
well,
okay,
I can kind of see how that makes sense.
Yeah,
that's one way of looking at it.
There's two,
by the way,
not just in this is,
I mean it's easy to be like,
hey,
he got to do all this stuff,
but if they're doing good work scientifically and for,
you know,
medical schools and stuff like this is obviously they're teaching people,
they're probably,
you know,
making breakthroughs in,
in,
you know,
discoveries in the field and stuff that's going to help people in general,
you know.
Now here's the other way I'm going to frame it for you is from the eyes of that
mother who's in that gas chamber,
who's watching that switch gets turned and she knows it's going to kill her and
her child.
And there's no,
there's no redemption is zero.
Nope.
Check.
Good job.
Try to lighten up the mood over here.
[inaudible].
Hey man,
you know.
All right.
Well Hey,
let's talk some porch some so we could support dwelling.
We're dwelling in our,
we're breaking,
breaking our,
our own code here.
Okay.
We're dwelling it code.
Yes.
All right,
well let's
talk about origin.
I feel like we should talk about origin and the first thing about origin that I
will talk about is the geese,
the flagship
product ease all in America by the way,
a rash guards as well.
This is you just too by the way specifically but not limited to so while the
Geezer kind of limited to,
unless you want to make a dragon weaves to suit like you're the one who
recommended you because you can do judo in that in a,
yeah,
I guess technically you could do karate too if you want.
Technically.
I mean but they're made for Jujitsu.
The rash guards made for Jujitsu,
but you can use it for like cycling and body boarding and what not.
Yeah.
Anything that you want to protect yourself from.
Rashes,
not epic,
not germ rashes like rash rashes.
Actually it does have a anti microbial stuff in it is true.
It is kind of protected from it anyway,
or demean.com that's where you can get this stuff all made in America and also
joggers
coming from the connoisseur have of comfort himself.
That's me.
Self comment about that.
Yes.
The you're,
you're now becoming known.
Yeah.
Maybe you could parlay that into like a whole thing.
Yeah,
like a whole thing.
Yeah.
Just have your own thing going on.
Not Wasting things for all.
Establish a standard of comfort.
It will be called the concert of comfort scale.
You see what I'm saying?
You know how like in temperature there's like Kelvin Celsius Fahrenheit.
Yup.
I'll beat that for company Echo scale,
Echo,
scale of comfort,
what would the highest level of comfort be?
Would it just be one to 10 you know,
it'd be,
uh,
well,
Jay would be the highest ranking Oj origin joggers.
Oh Damn.
I'm over here.
I'm like Pete,
for some reason he's a kind guy.
I like to just call,
you know how you like you'll text someone,
hey,
I want to,
you don't really,
but nowadays we like to text people.
You don't live it.
I'm not going to bother them.
I'm not going to,
you know,
but I don't know.
For some reason I like to call Pete,
so call them and I'll be like,
hey,
when's the shorts coming out?
Not First of all,
we can,
you know,
cause I want to wear them,
that kind of stuff.
Anyway,
so I'm about to call him and be like,
hey,
we need more colors of joggers or whatever.
But here's the thing,
Dewey,
I need more colors so I can't just be running Pete around his factory,
making new colors.
Just for me personally or maybe you can't.
I Dunno.
But it would help.
But yeah,
they're,
they're real good joggers and tee shirts and hoodies and whatnot.
Good stuff,
mate.
Origin made in America,
made in America,
which is good on a whole bunch of different levels.
Also,
we've got a bunch of supplements.
We got joint warfare,
we got Krill oil,
we got discipline,
which is good to drink before you get after it.
Mentally or physically.
And also we got milk.
Yeah.
But back to joint warfare.
Okay.
So let me get it.
I know you're wondering how my arm is doing.
I know,
I know.
Right.
I'll let you know.
So I went to Oregon,
the Oregon coast last week.
One week,
forgot the joint warfare.
Oh,
I just had surgery on my bicep.
About six.
Yeah,
six weeks ago.
And you know,
I would have FedEx you some bro.
I know.
Uh Yeah.
And thank you.
But you know,
I did.
How long did it take before you notice it?
Um,
I'm,
I'm guessing the moral of the story is this didn't work out good.
So,
and here's the thing.
My surgeon is good.
He was good.
He did a good job on my Arab,
reattached my bicep tendon to my bone,
drill the hole in the bone.
Boom.
Stick it through so it up cause she gets,
she gets Yalta.
Right.
Um,
so I take joint warfare and the thing feels good.
Like I'm way ahead of schedule,
you know,
surprisingly because I had it done in my alarm nine years ago,
blah,
blah.
So it's all good.
I'm moving around,
I'm doing like push ups doing stuff that no way I could get,
I could have done with,
with my other arm last time.
So I got to the Oregon coast,
forget that joint warfare.
I attribute it to the joint more for how far I had I am.
So I forget that.
Joint Warfare.
I'm in the Oregon coast,
I would say about two days.
And here's the thing in start like hurting or going backwards,
nothing like that.
But he was just this weird stiffness that sorta disagree.
Like I couldn't straighten it out right away and when I wake up,
you know,
I can't like,
I kind of got to work it out and it slowly just started to stiffen up a little
more.
And here's the thing,
I was way less active on it to where,
because when I do like pushups and stuff where I'm using my elbow a lot,
um,
it'd be kind of stiff that night,
you know.
Then the next day he loosened up and then it stronger.
You know,
it's just one of the things like muscles.
But,
um,
so I wasn't doing that.
Not much activity and it was just general stiffness.
Yeah.
Brah I was like,
I don't want to say it felt inflamed,
but it felt like,
you know,
you know how like you sprain your thumb or something like that and it's like
swollen and it's like just jammed up.
He can use it.
But anyway,
it kind of felt like that functional but not optimal functional,
whatnot,
not option optimal.
And then I come back two days back on the joint warfare boom,
back in the game,
full on back in the game.
That's pretty cool.
In the rear for hell of a thing then.
Good close to me.
Could Drayton,
curcumin good for your brain too,
by the way?
Just like discipline.
Also milk as you were saying with methe,
first of all,
most awesome.
Second of all,
what is milk?
It's milk.
Everyone knows that now.
I think that's pretty much going to be the new thing.
Um,
and we have peanut butter.
Chocolate will be coming out.
Oh,
I want to say,
I want to say within a week you're all like,
yeah,
we have his rudder.
And Chuck,
we have peanut butter and chocolate coming in about a week maybe?
No,
no,
no.
It's not even a,
maybe it's a straight up one week counting down the days.
Okay,
that's good.
So milk,
protein,
how many,
how much or how many grams of protein in milk?
22 first group.
So,
and I heard this,
I recently,
actually,
I didn't read it.
I saw it on a video youtube video.
I know that sounds liquor or youtube video button.
This one had credibility.
So
I,
you know,
Eh,
so you need,
not need,
but a good amount of protein is one gram.
They thought it was like 1.5 we were trying to build muscle and all this stuff.
But it's changed.
It's about,
yeah.
According to this,
it's like 0.7 or something like this.
I don't know.
I need more than that.
And we're gonna tell you right now.
All right,
well there you go.
Mark.
Get it.
And it tastes good.
Real good by the way.
It's dessert.
Yeah.
Any was more classified as a dessert.
That's the question to me currently.
It's currently,
it would have to be proven.
I literally eat my dinner and then I'm all excited to have more.
It is a dessert and I went on a trip and I haven't figured out how to travel
with milk yet,
which is a real bummer.
But you know,
it's a scoop.
You can't bring six scoops and I'm real light traveler.
And so now when I go somewhere and I get whatever,
I'll get a good meal,
I'll get a legit meal,
but I want to dessert.
Yeah,
I want milk.
You put it in a Ziploc bag puff.
Not In your carry on.
By the way,
then you've got gotta bring a Shaker.
Right.
There's this multiple problems that I have.
I've got to figure it out.
I'll figure it out a to figure it out.
One thing I can say is too is when I,
when I,
I've always,
if I drink protein shakes in the past I would have to use a big shaker
and brought a lot,
put price,
16 ounces of milk.
One thing that's good about mark and cause that's the only way that you feel
satisfied with Mulkey.
You can use one of the small little shakers.
So this is a possibility.
See,
I'm creating ideas right now.
Sure.
I can be one of the small shakers,
bring a little bit of milk in it and then just hit it up and we'll be good
because you don't need a big giant Shaker cause you don't need to drink that
much milk to feel like,
like you got enough dessert.
Anyway,
back to the deal.
Uh,
emerging camp.
Yep.
Winter jackets coming August 26 26 through September 2nd.
This is weird,
but we might,
it looks like we might actually sell out at a certain point.
How do you sell out of the cat?
I didn't think we'd be,
so if you want to come get registered because it,
we're probably going to end up because you can look,
we,
we have,
we already bought more mats,
double the Mat,
so we had to muster.
Yeah.
It's a lot of maths but still,
I mean there's still a limit.
So if you want to come to that,
come,
uh,
I'll be there.
Echobee there.
Dave Burke will be their life Leif and we'll be there.
Jps on the fence.
Dean lister,
Dean List will be there.
Sure.
Yeah.
And that's good.
Where you know,
when you learn stuff at the,
I mean there's there,
you know there's there,
you're going to learn specific things from specific people and all that stuff,
but
don't look at it like this thing where you're gonna go and you're just going to
learn what they have to teach you.
You know,
they're going to teach you spider guard 15 or 20 black belts there.
Yes.
So on top of that,
if you made it your goal,
if you went and you went and you said went to each one of those 15 black belts
and said,
show me your move your best move.
Yeah.
If you did that and he walked away,
that would be,
that would be solid.
But you,
you couldn't,
this is not,
this isn't a,
Hey,
show me your move and you spend three minutes.
No,
I'm talking.
If you,
if you spent like an hour,
maybe even an hour and a half going over,
what's your best move?
Like I bet I could teach certain moves for an hour and a half.
Yeah.
And just show every little detail.
If you came to the immersion camp and that's what you did,
you'd be rocking out of their [inaudible].
It'd be rough if everyone did that because you know it'd be hard.
I don't think you could,
I don't think you could logistically do it.
But I will say this,
that on top of what all the instructors there and not dimension,
just other experienced people,
what they have to offer and teach you.
You can come and be like,
my rear naked choke needs work.
This is how I do it.
Eight Jocko,
come here.
This is a tall,
I do it.
This is all day by the way,
you,
you have this opportunity.
This is how I do it and show.
Well that's,
that's one thing that you could do because you can't just literally train the
entire time,
but you can get shown moves and you can work moves oil.
You can't just train cause you'll die.
You'll die for sure.
But if,
but the point is there though where you can come and you can come to immersion
camp.
Right.
And it's good again,
to learn from,
from everything that everyone has to teach.
But you can go in with specific questions up with your game where are used to
like,
oh,
for sure,
how am I going to get better?
Of course my Jesus is going to get better in general.
That's good.
Of course.
But if it's like,
wait,
well,
my mount,
if you,
if you get more of your mount escapes get better,
then that's what you focused on.
And you could ask actually,
while I'll give you this advice,
if you have trouble being mounted it and escaping them out,
a good person to ask about that is actually Echo Charles.
You have a very good,
uh,
mountain scape.
Well,
yes,
very teachable.
That's one of your best moves is the amount of escape.
I will say that right now,
authoritatively brought all got a good amount of scape.
Thanks Bro.
Also shifting gears,
so yeah.
Anyway,
but yeah.
Immersion camp,
August 26th to September 2nd origin main.com for all that crap that we just
talked about,
or do you mean exactly right?
Main,
like the state and Mai and orchard.
[inaudible] dot com also,
if you want to get these cool shirts that say discipline equals freedom,
Jocko is a store.
It's called Jocko store,
so go to Jocko store.com.
Um,
they,
anyway,
that's where you can get the shirts that say discipline equals freedom.
Get after it anyway.
If you want to represent with Jocko gear,
it's more the philosophy.
It's not Jocko gear doesn't really have your face on it or nothing.
Oh wait,
yes it does have your face on it and it says good.
One of them.
Maybe two,
one,
two,
I don't know.
Anyway,
go there Jacqueline,
store.com if you like something,
get something you want to represent in your towel.
Also,
rash guards on their hoodies,
on their t shirts,
rash guards,
truckers,
hats.
You like the flex fit.
Flex.
Say I like hats.
I don't wear a hat.
Yeah,
my head got to get a Tan,
but actually I did.
I went in phases not to go to do.
You said you were going to get me much more of these truckers hats and you did
not.
Which one does,
this was them or deaf course.
Deaf Korea.
Uh,
they're on the way.
They're being embroidered right now.
Okay.
Actually I added like a bonus color of the,
I don't support bonus colors.
A bonus.
No,
but it's like a khaki,
uh,
like uh,
like a brown,
like a 10 Roscoe and tactically
pay.
Anyway,
Jaclyn zeroed out,
calm.
A lot of good stuff.
Do you just stuff on their women's stuff on there?
Oh,
I have to meet these whatnot.
Some posters on there too.
By the way,
you didn't even know about that today because a lot of people,
and I mean for real,
a lot of people like a lot,
a lot like seven.
One of the posters of a discipline equals freedom and the good poster,
those are the ones that people would hit me up often.
Very often be like,
Hey,
my gym,
I want to poster.
I want a poster from my room I want to post for,
from my office,
you know,
24 by 36 posters.
It's two posters on there.
I'll make other,
other ones.
But yeah,
that's some post show back a boom.
Represent in your gym and your office and your home.
I got one in my home.
First thing when you walk in,
it's interesting.
A poster of our podcasts did good poster.
That's cool.
Yeah,
so your face is kind of sorted there,
you know,
representing in my house.
Thanks Junkie.
By the way.
Also good way to support the podcast is to subscribe to the podcast on iTunes
and Google play,
stitcher,
wherever you listen to,
to podcasts.
Interesting how there's so many of them out there now.
There's a lot of podcasts.
No platform,
sorry.
Yeah,
the platform.
A lot of podcasts and there's a lot of podcast platforms,
but yes,
it's the new media,
the new media,
new media for bullies is they say,
yeah,
it,
his voice,
his voice.
Uh,
also in addition to this podcast,
which is called the Jocko podcast,
there's also the warrior kid podcast,
which is for kids.
But I promise you can get a lot out of it as an adult too.
Cool thing I've been doing on that.
I've done it twice.
I'm going to do it more,
but,
so it's questions for uncle Jake is the basic premises premise of it.
But now I have stories from Uncle Jake and the stories from Uncle Jake are
actually from uncle Jake's childhood and they kind of a lesson to people.
Yeah.
So that's number podcast number 14 and 15 are the first two that I've started
doing stories from Uncle Jake.
So I think people will like those.
Yeah,
yeah,
they're good.
So this kind of like character development sprinkled in there with the lesson to
me,
the less than one,
and I'm um,
maybe this is intentional,
but the lesson is the primary thing course and it's deep.
It's deep thing.
They're very,
uh,
consistent with the whole uncle Jake.
Way Simple lesson of the idea is I'm explaining how uncle Jake got his values
yeah.
From experiences that he went through as a child.
Yeah.
And their,
the stories are five minutes,
eight minutes,
something like that.
Yeah.
They're,
they're,
they're pretty short stories,
but they're cool and they're enjoyable.
So warrior kid podcast,
you can check that one out.
It's,
it's good.
And if kids,
if your kids have questions from Frankel,
Jake,
just hit,
hit me up on Twitter.
Send them to Twitter and I'll capture them.
Yep.
Good one.
Also,
youtube,
subscribe to the Youtube Channel.
We do have a youtube channel.
If you're interested in the video version of this podcast,
if you want to see echoes editing skills.
Sure.
Some people say you went over the top.
I'll go over the top from you.
There's a video called warpath.
It's,
it's probably the most controversial video from my perspective because it was
originally made with Christmas music,
which I don't like Christmas music and acclimated with Christmas music and he
put a lot of time and effort into it.
Christmas if we want to talk leadership here,
like from my perspective,
I knew you'd been working really hard on this thing and then you showed it to me
and the Christmas music kicked in,
which I didn't like,
didn't match,
but you know,
I just had to be like,
hey man,
it's great.
I really appreciate it.
You all,
that's a great video.
So I lied to you.
Is that a lie?
You didn't say great.
No,
you did not lie.
Okay.
You said,
and I quote interesting choice music for this one.
That's now.
I also will say that I don't a hundred percent trust myself.
Like I think to myself,
well echo really liked Christmas music,
so he put it in there,
so that's fine if that,
maybe some other people will like it too.
And that's,
I'm not here to like dictate what people like and don't like.
I'm just here to tell you what I like and don't like.
But then you,
but then you read it the video with with more appropriate music.
Sure.
Which is good,
but,
but then some people said you got crazy,
you went too far with,
you went through for you.
Too much stuff exploded.
You've got too much stuff going on.
There's the same amount of explosion.
I know what I'm saying.
I never really paid too much attention to what people say because I couldn't
even get past the music once I got past the music and I check the youtube
comments,
which I know,
right.
Yeah.
You know,
I went there and people,
some people,
the
majority of people,
yeah.
Said amazing.
Right,
the mature.
Some people just threw it out there.
Hey,
take it easy bro.
You can't,
you crossed the line,
right?
If you went over lunch,
I think you were around the line.
Yeah.
I think you might've,
you know,
stepped the tone a little bit,
but we have to find out where the line is.
Right?
Yes.
And I think you did a good job of pressing up against mine without just getting
into,
well let me,
uh,
let me tell you the philosophy into,
and tell me if this is a good way to approach it.
Put so a lot of those videos.
Okay,
so consider the first one we did good,
right?
It's the first one.
Okay.
Good job.
Out of the gate.
I think I might've told the story like there's a story behind,
but we're recording podcast.
He was like number three or five,
one of the first initial ones.
And I was like,
oh,
my camera was sitting over there behind,
kind of behind,
over in the corner.
And if you notice on good when it shows you,
you can see like it's behind like a monitor and see.
You can see this style.
I just went and pressed,
I kind of moved the camera a little bit and I just press record before you said
that,
that part.
And I was like,
Oh,
I'm going to record this just in case I'll make,
I'll make a video,
a lot of it or something,
or like,
okay,
whatever.
And if you look at it and watch it the other day,
we're like,
Joe Rogan guys were talking about it.
And so I was like,
Oh,
let me watch it.
You know?
And I remember thinking,
and you're like reading and when you're looking up,
like you're looking at me and I remember you saying this stuff to me and I'm
like,
fuck,
this is crazy.
This girl,
I'm glad I'm recording it.
But that wasn't made.
It wasn't like,
okay,
we're going to do this,
we're going to record this and we're going to do that.
You know?
It was just like,
oh,
I'm going to try to make a fun video out of it,
and then just put some random like graphics on there that it was just having fun
doing.
So these videos you do it,
they're kind of done out of just fun,
you know,
and,
and every once in a while,
hey man,
you have too much fun,
you grab some sound effects and you make the walls crumble,
you do kind of stuff.
You know,
you have some fun with it.
I mean there's no,
I guess there is kind of their thematic I guess.
Right?
There's some theme to it.
Like warpath it's kind of,
for me it's like it's,
it's pretty awesome to watch.
I could see where you're like,
I can see where you start going down the path of like just more is better.
Yeah.
And that's really what happens and I'll catch myself doing it and it'll take a
long ass.
I,
I'm like Bro,
this is not even necessary.
And in fact,
in some people they will bring up this point,
which is a good point where I put stuff combine right for,
okay,
poor power to take warpath for example,
I put the walls crumbling and Jacqueline Dean Rolling.
And when they,
when they clash,
like the walls come chattering down,
it's all these special effects,
which is like cool when you look at it.
But all the special effects,
the sound effects and like all this stuff,
it's like,
is it kind of getting in the way of the message?
Because the message is like you're saying something specific,
you know,
so it's kind of getting in the way,
you know?
So I got to watch out for that.
Yeah.
And I think that's a good point.
When people say that,
I'm like,
Dang,
that's true.
And because you don't know when you're in the Mitchell or stoked.
Yeah,
I guess.
But I,
yeah,
I've got to watch him.
You're right.
Uh,
a,
there's also a warrior kid youtube channel.
Okay.
So the reason that we separated the warrior kid and the warrior kid and the
Jocko podcast,
channel channel,
blah,
is because we know that there's things on this podcast and on the therefore on
the youtube channel Jocko podcast,
there's stuff that's inappropriate for children to listen to or watch.
And so this is a way to separate them.
So there's also a warrior kid youtube channel that your kid can sit there and
watch and hopefully I'm not guaranteeing because I don't know how the algorithms
work that pop up the next video selections,
but hopefully your kid can watch the warrior kid videos without getting hooked
into the unit.
Seven 31 customer about pivot section.
So watch out for that.
Yup,
true story.
And that one's in color too by the way
as it were.
Also good way to support yourself is to get some new gear if you work out to
boring,
gives them the new gear from on it by the way on it.com/jocko good place to go.
Good information too about starting your kettle bell workout brows.
And I just thought of this yesterday was in the pool with my daughter and my
wife was saying,
you know,
you know how like,
okay,
so you might seem like Bj Penn do this,
where he'll go on the bottom of the ocean and it'll carry this in Hawaii.
So I'm like,
Hey,
you could grab one of those kettlebells.
And,
and my daughter,
she's five.
So she was like,
good.
I was like,
yeah,
go grab the little,
it's like,
it's like a Pixie or I don't know.
I don't know what it is,
but it's like one of those a ledge and bells.
It's a small one that,
that I got for.
So she grabs it and she goes in the pool.
She's like,
I'm going to,
and I say,
yeah,
walk to the other side.
And it's like,
she goes kind of into the deep section.
So she goes and she's carrying it.
She's doing the whole Bj Penn with the little kettle bells five by the way,
under the water.
And we're watching it.
We're like,
oh,
that's cute.
But she starts to sort of run out of air and she didn't want to drop the kettle
bell cause it's like going to slam and the bottom of the pool.
And I don't know,
maybe she just,
she's five,
she didn't think of that,
you know,
kind of thing.
So I see her trying to like swim with it,
like trying to get to the top and it's kind of deep pen.
I was like,
oh I started to get worried and then she started a little bit more urgency so I
had to jump in,
grab her echo with the save save.
But she did right when I got tour,
she put it up on the little,
there's a little ledge and the other side of the pool there.
She managed to do it just,
but just barely.
So I went in there
when my middle daughter was probably eight,
eight years old and we had a party at the beach for our birthday or a ward.
And so I was dealing with,
I could as long as I could,
I was dealing with the games and the whatever.
And finally I'm like,
you know what?
That's it.
We're going,
we're going to get some.
So we formed the party up into two teams and we're going to compete against each
other and obstacle courses and sprints and all this other stuff's sure.
And this particular location has a river gentle flowing tidal river that comes
out.
And anyways,
one of the contest I had was,
okay you,
we've got a swim across and there's big rocks and stuff.
And I go,
you gotta swim across the river and come back.
And whoever brings back the biggest rock is the winner.
So my middle daughter is tall off,
she's tough and she's strong.
She's a wrestler and gymnastics and all that crap and we're not crap and all
that stuff.
You know,
like she's just,
um,
she's a beast and she's mentally like,
I don't want to use the term psycho,
but like he's real determined about stuff sometimes.
So anyways,
this is when she's a little kid,
you know,
and so go,
go across the river and whoever brings back the biggest rock wins.
So she goes,
so they all go across and kids are grabbing rocks that are size of let's say,
let's say a softball,
maybe a softball.
What's in between the size of a softball and a soccer ball?
Uh,
I dunno some,
so some.
Okay.
Loaf of bread,
like,
like maybe a small loaf of bread.
That's the Max,
right,
that any of these kids are grabbing.
My daughter grabs something that's like the size of a,
like a legit watermelon.
Big Giant,
giant,
giant rock to hand.
Oh Two hand rock,
rob giant rock,
like four or five loaves of bread.
Just a big,
big giant rock.
And I'm watching her and I'm thinking,
well,
she's just going to sink to the bottom and still have to let it go and still
have to go back and get it smaller one.
Maybe she can still do.
Okay.
So she and the river has weird contours on the bottom.
You know,
you're,
you can walk a little while and then it just drops super deep and you just got
to make it.
So I'm watching her and she's,
she's,
she's hard for even carry it and she cares.
He gets to that deep section,
just drops down,
goes under,
and I'm waiting for it to pop up,
but she doesn't pop up and I'm waiting for it to pop up and she doesn't pop up
and a waiting for it to pop up and she doesn't pop up.
And then I see like an air bubble come up and I'm like,
Oh Dang.
But the air bubble has progressed.
So now I'm watching the air bubbles like progress.
They're coming closer to the other side and,
and then it starts to come up and sure enough out she comes like a,
like a beast.
He's in the Rock,
she comes up out of the water,
powered through that and brings the rock up,
drops it at my feet.
No great victory.
He's yours.
That's actually pretty powerful because Braille when
you're,
I mean,
unless she was like demands on our mindset,
so her,
she was probably like,
I'm not gonna let this rock defeat me.
I'm going to bring to the other side.
And that's kind of the mindset.
I'm not going to drop it for that reason.
I think my daughter did was like,
I'm can't drop this thing so I'm stuck with it,
you know,
kind of thing.
That's what you know.
So she started,
you could tell she was a little bit going into panic mode.
Yeah.
So it's a whole different scenario technically.
But that's pretty savage though.
He do you think that I should cause she's [inaudible] she's scared.
She even said like later like,
oh that was like scary and all this stuff.
I should probably make her do it again.
Yeah.
Not make her like do it,
but like maybe jump in with there.
My daughter,
my youngest daughter just did the big cliff jump yesterday and long swim in the
ocean.
Open,
open ocean waters.
I know you got to get him.
And she was,
I was,
I thought she was gonna be panicky.
Yeah.
Cause it's drop and it's ocean and whatever.
And this is what's the wave action.
But she was,
I sit down,
you're good.
And she said,
yeah,
you do it too.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That they usually,
I mean unless she got traumatized by it or something like this where Brown Mike,
what's weird come from Hawaii.
You jump off everything.
Water.
Yeah.
You see,
so we have this ledge that,
you know,
you saw it and it's not that high,
but for a one year old it's pretty high.
It's pretty good.
My boy and my daughter when she was one too,
they just jump off.
We'd catch them,
they can't swim yet.
And my son,
he jumped off a few times and it was all good.
But then one time he went to walk in,
there was this little just little slight little dip and you know when you're,
you,
you know you're new to walk.
He slipped,
he tripped and he fell in.
I caught him but he full on like hate his side on the edge of the thing and he's
getting,
he's crying.
He's one and just,
just over one maybe like made him do it again.
He didn't want to do it though,
but so I didn't like push them again.
I just kept like,
Hey,
do it.
I got you,
I got you.
And He'd be like,
Eh,
you know,
crying and whatever.
And then,
you know,
my daughter would do it,
I would do it.
Then he finally like reluctantly did it and we cheered for him and now he's all
good.
Good to go.
Like forces himself.
He makes me catch them now.
Cheese,
he's like almost too.
Anyway.
But yeah.
The,
the point is you make them do it again,
right?
Yeah.
But you're very accurate in saying don't traumatize him.
Like going right down the hall,
come off now it's just getting worse.
You're not,
you're not,
you know,
it's like the hey do it.
Gee,
you should do it.
Oh you want to take a little break?
That's okay.
But you know,
you should definitely do this is it,
you've already done it before.
You don't want to traumatize them worse.
That's not going to work out good.
Yeah.
Especially with the Waterman.
Cause it's like,
it's one minute,
it's all fun and games and literally your mind can flipped.
You know,
like I'm about to die.
I used to say this,
so in the 90s in the seal teams when there was no war going on and whatever,
you'd go out and you do training.
There was times I would always tell guys,
when you're working in the water,
it's
a real world mission.
Like we didn't know what a real world mission got.
Never been on one.
But the fact of the matter is when you're working with the water,
it's a real world mission because if you screw something up you can easily die
easily.
If you're not careful,
one up,
one down,
just going to throw it out there.
If you're doing any kind of this training and you're training the water,
one person stays up on the surface.
The of the person you know and be a lifeguard,
you don't do simultaneous training in the water.
So just throwing that out there was a little safety note for everyone.
One Up,
one down.
That's the rule.
Yes.
And especially if you're carrying the kettle bells from audit or otherwise at
the bottom of the pool,
the bottom of the ocean,
bottom of a reservoir,
bottom of anybody have water.
Yup.
One Up,
one down,
one on one day.
Nonetheless.
So that's how we utilize the Pixie.
I think it's called Pixi.
It's one of the legend belts.
Anyway,
if,
I guess that doesn't really have much to do with what on it offers,
but it just,
I just thought of that cause it just happened nonetheless.
Hey,
he was represented in the story.
Boom.
Anyway,
if you want cool fitness stuff on it.
DOTCOM slash Jocko.
A lot of good information on there.
Some socks on there.
I mentioned the socks,
like it's like this big deal.
And here's the thing.
It is on its socks of the TSA.
The other day I had to stun on like on.
It sucks,
right?
Issues,
you know,
they're looking,
they're like,
those are dope sucks.
Anyway,
I ended up on slash chocolate.
It's a good spot.
A psychological warfare is an album that you can get where I talk about stuff of
overcoming when you have little moments of weakness and I'm gonna make another
one good and make another one.
Got a gun plotting on it.
Good.
It looks like it's going to be called.
All your excuses are lies.
Yes.
Good.
I could title you get that iTunes,
Google play wherever.
MP3S herself.
Yeah man.
Amazon and also Jocko white tea people have now seen that we have cans of Jocko
white tea.
Where do you get them?
You get them on Amazon if you want them.
It tastes awesome.
You can get the dried tea on there too,
which you've had water to.
And then you brew it.
And then if either one,
you're going to get an 8,000 pound deadlift.
So that's cool you do that.
Got Some books where the warrior kid and Mark's mission two books.
Which one do you like better?
Do I like better?
I can't say because the first one,
the Oji,
the original one from wimpy to warrior will always have.
That's the one that established establishes the ethos in my house anyway.
Um,
but yeah,
no,
I can't say.
I think they're both outstanding,
but it's good how you evolve the issues,
you know,
like it's like bull basically.
Think about how many people were like,
oh,
you're going to write more.
Well,
yeah.
What are you gonna write about?
Think about all the issues you have as a human being and then you think about
all the issues you had as a kid.
Like we're going to cover all of us.
Yeah.
That's like 10 books,
right?
Uncle Jake's got some help for you.
So yeah,
way the warrior kid books,
they,
the one thing that's cool is people as a parent,
you're like,
man,
how do I get my kid to even something as stupid as cleaning your room,
right.
How do you get your kid to clean your room?
Hadn't read this book.
I got pictures,
I got,
I just got a picture on Twitter the other day.
Kids kind a vacuum cleaner and the dad's a pump it pump.
He's like,
look at this.
That's a real thing.
Even as I'm like,
okay,
so kids read the book of course,
but I read it to my daughter who was four at the time for,
yeah.
So I'm reading it and it's answering a bunch of questions I have.
So it's like,
hey,
you know,
my kid,
my daughter was like,
okay,
what do you mean parenting questions?
Yes,
exactly.
Right.
So,
and it's just little stuff,
little stuff sometimes you won't even really think of.
So like,
okay,
for example,
and I said,
I mentioned this one before,
but it's a huge deal that I still use it like it's on the front of my mind every
single time.
So you know how like you'll have a kid and they'll be like real good at
something,
just kind of right away.
Maybe your kids more athletic or something and maybe they're bigger,
taller,
whatever.
So they kind of win real quick,
you know?
So when they run into a situation where they're in an activity that actually
requires practice,
like a cartwheel or something like this.
And so my daughter,
she's being,
she's athletic little girl,
way bigger,
she's a,
you know,
and so she has this friend,
same age,
she's like a week,
either older or younger,
I forget,
but they're the same age and she can do a cartwheel and just fly through
cartwheels.
One handed cartwheels hold this stuff,
this other girl can,
she is way smaller in a way,
whatever.
So my daughter,
she doesn't like that.
Not the fact that the girl can,
but just she can't.
So she tries to do it.
She can kind of starts,
you know,
it's a whole thing.
It's very upsetting.
So uncle Jake said something in the first one that this will always stick with
me when she complained to me about it.
You can't grow and do a cartwheel and how Malia can do a cartwheel,
but I can and all this stuff
I see.
And that cool uncle Jake,
how do you expect to be good at something when you've never practiced the boom?
Just like the times table.
Yeah.
I ain't gonna be good at times,
so it wouldn't,
he never studied,
you know,
and it makes it known how to do a cartwheel.
You're not born knowing how to do a cartwheel.
Just like,
oh,
you know,
our other neighbor can play the guitar.
You know,
how much practice,
you know,
kind of thing.
And it's crazy because just that simple line right there,
she was four and she understands,
you know,
she's like practicing breath.
Anyway,
that's how,
that's how they look.
Good Warrior kid books.
There's two of them were the were your kid and Mark's mission.
You can get those.
You can also get disappointed equals freedom.
The field manual.
Yeah.
Field manual.
How to get after it.
Yeah.
Simple as that.
The audio version of that is not on audible.
It's on Itunes,
Amazon,
music,
all that stuff.
Also,
extreme ownership.
Extreme ownership is on audible and I just looked,
it was number two on apple,
audible books,
whatever that's called.
Apple I books or something.
Number two right now.
The book's been out for almost three years.
What is apple?
I books.
It's where you can get books for your eye.
For audio books.
Yeah.
Sorry.
Yeah,
yeah,
no worries.
Oh,
speaking of books,
by the way,
it,
if you want to get this one.
Oh unit seven 31 31 yeah.
I'm putting on the lens unit seven 31 just that.
Yeah.
That subtitle is Japan secret biological warfare in World War II.
Dark book,
but see,
really see strongly.
I feel strongly that that's like one,
you can't know.
One are crazy,
but yeah.
Anyway,
I'm gonna put them on our website,
Jocko podcast.
Someone just hit me up on Twitter that he's like,
hey,
we,
we had a long road trip for 4th of July,
my wife,
me and my kids aged 13 whatever.
Listen to one 21 one 22 and one 23.
Yeah.
That's real significant.
I,
you know,
I don't,
I don't know if I want to say it family time,
but like that's a real,
the compared to the other things that you could be doing in the car,
that's a real good thing to do in your car.
Introduce your kids to hit better history,
a bit of human nature,
a bit of the darkness of the world,
a bit of overcoming that darkness.
That's pretty cool.
These are the kinds of books.
Well,
so that's that.
But yeah,
these books,
you're,
you're saying he's the kind of books you kind of want to have.
It's,
I think it's important too.
I think it's important to know what's going on and know what has happened in the
world.
As I said.
Yeah.
You want to check that out?
Uh,
but yeah,
we'll put it on the,
on the website.
That's the point.
I'm gonna have a,
or we have it on the page books from that puzzle.
It's all by episode.
So this one's from obviously one 33 yep.
And,
and,
and also you've got on the website cause extreme ownership,
which I are talking about is the first book I wrote with my brother Leif Babin
and we wrote another book which is called the dichotomy of leadership.
That's also on the website,
right?
Yes.
Yeah.
And yeah,
so that's coming out September 25th if you want to get that on the first a dish.
Yeah man,
you can go for the third a dish though.
What's the difference between third and third edition in seventh edition?
Nothing.
Just same.
What's the different between first the dish and second a dish?
Well it's,
you are in the game.
It's kind of like the difference if you take,
if you run a race or if you're recognized and not recognized,
but let's say you run a race.
You first,
okay,
first place guys,
second got third place guy all get metals.
What is,
what is the metal made out of?
We'll just say metal for lack of better term.
What's the difference between the metal gold?
No,
nothing.
Only the color.
Psychological.
Oh,
it's all made the same stuff.
Bad analogy.
Yeah.
I don't even follow it,
but first edition,
that's the point.
That's what on talking to me first year,
and also if you want to bring myself Leif Babin JP
to know Dave Burke.
We got Mike Cirelli got Flint Cochran now on the team.
If you need help with leadership in your organization or whatever kind of
organization it is,
you can hit us up.
Ashkelon front is the name of the company.
We solve problems through leadership.
Ashkelon front dot cog.
Get some.
We have one more muster in 2018 it is in San Francisco.
It's October 17th and 18th
it's going to sell out.
I was,
I just got an update from Jamie today.
The OPS director at echelon front ensure.
She was saying that we're going to sell out a lot sooner than we thought,
so if you want to come up there,
extreme ownership.com the monster.
I'll put,
I got a video to post about that too.
I haven't posted it yet,
but yeah,
that's that.
Also on top of the muster we have the roll call,
which is for police,
military,
law enforcement,
firefighters and first responders.
It's for people in uniform.
That's happening September 21st in Dallas,
Texas.
It's only one day so you don't have to miss too much work.
It's a lower price point so you can afford it or you can get your organization
to pay for it a little easier.
Come on down to that.
It's a great program.
I just finished putting together the agenda yesterday and so come on down
until then if you want to kick it with us just a little bit more.
Sure.
Virtually until we are together live,
which we will be,
we'll be together live at the muster in San Francisco or at the roll call in
Dallas,
Texas or at the immersion camp in Maine.
We'll see you at one of those,
but until then,
if you do want to kick it with us,
we will be on the interwebs,
on Twitter,
on Instagram,
and on that base.
That bulky ball echo is that echo Charles and I am at Jocko Willink and of
course to all the military personnel that are listening.
Okay,
you provide the freedom that allows us to do what we do every day.
You also hold the line against the evil that we talked about today.
So thank you to police,
law enforcement,
firefighters,
paramedics,
border patrol,
other first responders.
You actually provide this safety that allows us to do what we do every day.
So thanks to you and to the families that support all those that serve.
Thank you
for supporting those families that serve and to everyone else that's listening.
Thank you for listening.
Thanks for supporting.
I know it was a rough list.
I know it is.
It's rough for me to read.
It's rough for me to talk about,
but it's also reality and if you don't face reality,
you can't fix it.
If you don't face your past,
you can't learn from it.
So what you have to do is you have to face him,
you have to face what scares you,
you have to face what bothers you.
You have to face your weaknesses.
And face your fears and face your own darkness.
Face them,
own them,
and overcome them all by stepping up
and getting after it.
And until next time,
this is echo and Jocko out.